good morning members of the planning
committee good morning members of the
public you're all welcome here this
morning for today's meeting on Wednesday
the 7th of
October may I first of all remind you
all of some of the domestic
arrangements please ensure that the
microphones and cameras are turned off
when not in use that you do not
interrupt other
speakers that if you wish to speak a
point of order declaration and or
interest or request an adjournment
please use use the hands up function on
the task bar members are reminded that
they should not have alternative
communication lines open I.E other scope
chats and that if you are contacted by a
third party during the application you
should bring this to the legal offer's
attention if that if you're attending
the
meeting to speak and persistently
interrupt the meeting you may be asked
to leave if members do lose connection
to the meeting they must contact the
member Support Officer Mandy Smith as
soon as
possible I would like to remind everyone
present that this meeting will be
broadcast live to the internet and will
be capable of repeated fings the hold of
the meeting will be recorded except
where are confidential or exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you will be deemed by the
council to have consented to being
recorded by entering this meeting as a
speaker you're also consenting to being
recorded by the council and to the
possible use of those sound recordings
for webcasting Andor training
purposes the canil members of the public
and press May film record photograph or
broadcast this meeting when the press
and public are not lawfully
excluded I'd like to introduce to the
officers for this morning's meeting they
are Mark Russell the area plan and
manager Joe Hobs case officer Sam
Summers who's a case officer for the
second
application Andy PR the plan and lawyer
and Robert car Michael the governance
officer I'd now like to move to the AG
agenda and item number one on the agenda
is apology
and substitutions if there's any I'm
going to ask the uh Governor officer
Robert kichel to do a roll call for
members
present good morning members if you
could please respond with can hardly
hear
you is that better chair not really oh
what's going on here
then
hello working B chair that's B apologies
that members I'm not quite sure what
happened there um if members could
please respond with um good morning or
present so councelor Su good morning
counc Melanie Barrett present counc
Peter beer present counc David Busby
morning counc John Hinton present
Council Lee Jameson morning counc
McLaren present councel Adrien Osborne
good morning
present councelor Alison Owen good
morning councelor Lee Parker present
councelor Steven Plum present and I'll
just check for the ward members I
believe we have councelor Zack Norman uh
president thank you counselor and I know
that coun I think I saw councelor
May yes present good morning good
morning counc and we've heard from
councel Ry that he will
slightly later on in the meeting if he
isn't listening at the moment so we're
all here chair I believe that we're
still waiting on a couple of the public
speakers um to get in we've got the one
of the
objectors
and
the a applicant um but we're just um I
believe my colleagues on the phone about
that but we'll go to the um we go
through the formalities chair and then
we can see where we are then yeah thank
you right uh we will move on then to
item two Declarations of Interest have
members got
any no no hands are up so I'll take that
as
no then we'll move to item three which
is to confirm the minutes of the meeting
held on the 23rd of
September um you've all seen these
now I think chair if I might just
interrupt um apologies there is one
slight Amendment to the minutes um that
I noted yesterday is in the merge for
some reason the um attendance of
officers and Ward members was missed off
so I would ask um that I'd be able to uh
put in the uh attendance for the meeting
um as part of a an
amendment uh well yes I should think
members agree to that because that's
that will be a true record she'll just
get it from the recording as to who
attended and uh the
members uh yes I think that would be
okay do I have a second for that to be
Proposal with that please councelor a
yeah and councelor Osborne yes propos
second um and that's with the amendment
that um Mr K has just referred to
absolutely thank you our inserts coming
up all over the place as well uh thank
you um is there any other
comments no then I'll ask uh Rob to do a
roll call
please thank you chair if members could
please respond with for against or
abstain so councelor Suz
for councelor melony Barrett
four councelor Peter Bo
four counc Dave Busby
four councelor John Hinton
four ccor Lee Jameson
four councelor Mary McLaren
four councelor Adrien Osborne four counc
Allison
Owen four councelor Lee Parker four and
councelor Steven Plum for thank you
chair that is
carried thank you well there'll be joed
at the next practical opportunity
members thank you very much now we'll
move on to item four which is receive
notifications to petitions in accordance
with the council's petition scheme uh
officers is there any of you're wishing
to call thank you chair we have one
petition to report this morning good um
so we have one received one petition
regarding regarding item 6A on the
agenda which is
dc9
0567 which is the application in spron
this was received with 240 valid sign
signatures supporting the following
statement we wish to voice a number of
strong objections that we have with
regard to the proposed development of
additional properties on open space to
the side of burto Lane and burto Lane
and Lorraine way also known as hope Farm
policies that are from the bber local
plan 2011 to 2031 core strategy and
policies part one of the new local plan
saved policies nppf Regional planning
guidance for East Anglia the suff
structure
plan1 all combined to support the
protection of our Countryside and green
belt areas thank you chair thank
you and um members is there any site
inspections you wish to
call I'll take that as no then thank you
so with no to that um we'll move on to
item six then which is the plan and
applications of determination by the
committee before we go into it uh Rob do
we have the other invited guests with us
now or are we still waiting right I'm
just checking
chair
so we have Mr levit we also have Rob
snowling we've
got Rona German I think the only person
we're missing chair and we've got
apologies councelor um Hudson I missed
you off earlier councelor Hudson is here
in his role as County counselor as well
so apologies for that counselor um the
only person we missing is counselor is
councelor Helen Davis of spron Parish
Council um I believe that it's possible
my colleague Claire could be on the
phone to her at the moment okay we'll
we'll give you a few minutes to see if
you can track it down okay thank you
chair
members and the members of the public
please bear with us we're just trying to
see if we can get the parish council
representative Halen Davis um she's down
to speak so we need to see if we can get
her to join us she may be experiencing
some
difficulties
for
um
[Music]
EX
Rob um perhaps if um at some point we
could start the
presentation um and then we could try
and see uh whether she's joined us by
the time we get to the public speaker
yes I think that'll be acceptable and as
time is moving on at that point I would
suggest that um I know that my colleague
CLA is working hard at the moment to try
and um get we'll give it until another
couple of minutes
9:45 and then if not perhaps the case
officer Joe Hobs will start the start
then okay yep thank you chair and then
we'll stop again to see whether she's
here by the time we get public
speakers
what a waiting shair are we looking at
any way that we can start site visits
again or we just accepted that the can't
happen I think the same uh answers
applies that they've been given us for
the last two or three months but I'll
ask Robert if you can comment on
that yes of course chair um as far as
I'm aware from the decision of the
Tactical management team of the council
the same decision um stands with regards
to site visit um on until that advice
changes I can't advise members of
anything else with regards to that but
um it is under review all the time as
things change with regards to covid as
do our day daily lives in that matter so
we we are not standing still on that one
Council Busby we're reviewing it with
the times as they change thank
you thank you right it's uh just gone
9:45 uh Cas officer Joe Hobs would you
like to um take us through the plan and
application for
spron thank you thank you chair members
it's on page 11 to
I'll just load up the um presentation B
one second
yeah okay chair can you see that on your
screen no I can just see you at the
moment H yes it's there now and I'm
assuming all members have got
it yep C Harry on okay lovely thank you
so the application before members today
uh is application dc19
0567 on land north of bur Lan in spron
which is just shown highlighted in green
on the map there the application is a
hybrid application uh it's part in
outline and part in full I will show
plans later on in the presentation that
show which parts are full and which
parts are outlined but just to give an
overview uh the uh full part is the
access road the actual precise location
of the spine Road and Associated
drainage and Highway works for that
spine Road and the outline component is
outline for 92 dwellings plus 13
self-build including 37 affordable
dwellings 35% within that extension to
allotments a community Woodland
relocated Caravan storage Village car
park and a community use shop or office
space
building um the application these parts
are in outline except for access the
access points for the site are fixed as
I'll show you later in the slides so
before I get into the presentation just
want to draw members attention to uh
tabled papers uh on page nine um 10 and
11 of tabled papers uh the updates for
this
application um apologies Joe I think
that there something's gone on here in
terms of controlling of the screen I
don't think you are lost it I have sorry
about
this I just think I just lost my red
outline on the screen let me try again I
think it might possibly be Mr
depre
oh have I done something CH no I oh
there we are it's gone back to Fantastic
sorry Jo thank you very much yeah that's
okay thank
you there we
go it's the the it's back up and again
members if you're not receiving it just
put a hands up and I'm assuming you're
all receiving it thank
you okay okay yes lovely on the tabled
papers um page nine there's some updates
to the committee report um there's a
matter on Heritage which I will cover
later in the Heritage part of the
presentation if that's okay um just some
additional comments on the
representations made just to make sure
that all matters are adequately covered
through the committee papers so I've
just added some further Clarity on the
Dark Skies issues that have been raised
and also um property value I've also
noted that a delivery statement has been
submitted in the member briefing notes
and that just supports further what's
already on page 42 of the agenda of the
committee report and just to update the
over 330 representations have been
received on the application previously
the committee report uh reported over
300 another final point I just want to
point out on the table papers is that
the
recommendation um we have amended it
slightly it's in full now on page 9 10
and 11 of the table papers that's just
to recognize that Natural England
haven't yet formally responded uh to the
final consultation on the appropriate
assessment for this application we're
not envisaging they will have any
objection the council's ecologist is
happy that we have enough information
now to assess this application in terms
of it recreational uh impact on
protected sites um but we are just
waiting for confirmation from Natural
England so we have sought delegated
authority um to to Grant consent once
that issue is resolved and if there are
any problems with that of course we'
bring it back with four
members um to further update since the
table papers were published uh members
may be aware that the council has just
uh published uh its revised housing land
Supply position and babber District
Council can now demonstrate 6.74 years
land Supply this doesn't materially
change the content of the applic of the
committee report for members uh the
committee report was written on the
basis the council can demonstrate a
5year land
Supply uh also one final point is we did
receive um comments from Council harder
he wanted to make the committee aware
that he fully supports the views of spr
Parish Council and councelor Zack Norman
I just wanted that to be known on the
record okay so just to go into the
application
now here we have an aerial uh flyover of
the site is showing spron the site is
shown in the Red Dot um I will go
through more Landmark features in a
second but I'm just going to play this
video which just shows the flyover from
Google Earth of the site um and just to
show you will spin round and show you
the context of spon site is just to the
Northwest there of spron
Village we
go and then just to highlight the site
there is just shown in Orange the extent
of the red
line and then we're just going to show
some locational content so we've got the
A14 along the back of the slide there
Sport and Enterprise Park you can
actually see the former sugar be Towers
there on the site this obious a slightly
older photo and we've got Lorraine way
along the site there the B1 1113 and
burto
Lane this is a site the site closer up
so we've got B 1113 the rain way along
the east of the site there burst Lane
along the South uh the grindle uh a road
uh through Road along the north of the
site and the High Street in spon and
lower
Street also just to point out I'll show
you more information later there foot
paath nine which uh goes across the
application site just to give some more
locational context we've got the Wildman
Public House on the junction here of
burto Lane and the B 1113 we've got
existing
allotments we've got All Saints Church
in spon the tie Barn Community shop and
existing Caravan storage site some
members may be aware of which is visible
from the road as you enter
spon now we're just going to run through
the constraints relevant to the
application uh the application site is
highlighted in Orange there spron is
designated as a hinin village and the
bab cor
strategy uh this is the existing builtup
area boundary you'll see the site sits
outside of it uh but of joining just uh
along some parts of the site there just
highlighted in green there if you can
just see that
the existing allotments were also
registered as an asset of community
value and these green uh shapes to show
you where foot path 9 is and other foot
paths that just run along the sides down
the grindle and footpath 22 which runs
along the east side of the river gipping
there and just showing you the uh the
route
through uh also we've got the
application site the site shown in green
there that's the extent of the special
landscape area uh to the north of this
slide is white but this is where the
boundary is with mid suffk you can just
see it just uh skirts along the uh north
of the application site there so that's
mid suffk there and just to show on the
south site uh south of burst or Lane
there are tree preservation orders but
they're not within the application
site so just to run through the listed
buildings we've got two maps of listed
buildings uh we've got ones uh in The
Wider area that just want to run through
uh we've got Fon Farmhouse grade two
thornbush Hall grade two runton house
grade two and we've got St Mary the
Virgin Church in brownford which is
grade one sport and Mana grade two and
then we have a cluster of uh listed
buildings in the Village Center we got
two uh we've got two and four lower
Street grade two Walnut Cottage uh lower
house and stores grade two and numbers
two and four um church close now I've
split these two slides into wider
Heritage assets and then Heritage assets
which are more affected by the proposed
planning application as detailed in the
committee report this slide shows the
key listed buildings that we've uh uh
have concerns over the Heritage time
with in the um with the assessment of
The Proposal we have the grindle house
on the location on the grindle which is
grade two we've got the Wildman Public
House on the corner there grade two and
then we have church of All Saints
um uh which is uh grade uh two star
listed building uh in the Village Center
there a second and there we go the tithe
barn and root Barn grade 2 and Sport and
Hall and Mill and Mill House grade
two I will go through more detail the
impact on the Heritage assets later in
the presentation so just the final three
constraints here we've got uh flood
zones 2 and three outside of the
application site but just wanted to show
you the extent of those there to the
east side of uh Lorraine way the site is
well located outside of those but there
are some areas of surface water
floodings are here we're just looking
along the grindle along the north of the
application site we've got uh the extent
of 1 in 30 chance of predicted surface
water flooding and one in 100 chance of
surface water flooding this matter is
considered further in the committee
report as you'll
see the agricultural land grade just one
final matter we've got grade two
agricultural shown in brown uh the
application site is now outside of this
and and grade three agricultural land
which the application SES Falls
within so I'm going to show some videos
and photos of the site now I appreciate
members May well have viewed the virtual
site visit material but just for
completeness um I will need to show the
uh videos uh uh of the site to give some
context this presentation so video two
will'll travel South down the B 11:13
video 3 will come up lower Street and
cross over on to burst or lane and then
video 4 will come down burst or Lane
show the other View and um just to
highlight the footpath N that's the
route through the site which hope your
members are aware of now so if I just
play the videos as we're just coming
into the village
here we've got the Caravan storage the
existing 30 M speed limit Caravan
storage to the right of the site there
there's an existing field access the
posed site access will be just here on
the right side of the
slide and here we travel to the uh
allotments on the right of the slide now
and the Wildman Public House to the
right there we've got the junction with
lower Street and on the left best or
Lane on the right and now we're
traveling down um High
Street just want to give members uh uh
some context of the um highways and the
traffic issues as they have been raised
in a large number of the representations
made on the
application okay and then if we move to
the video on Lower street so this just
taken from church close you can see
sporton Manor uh Straight Ahead in
sporton Hall sorry straight ahead in the
uh photo there and now we're just moving
to go past the tithe Barn towards the
Wildman Public House at the
junction
again just to show some of the um the
traffic issues on the um Street
obviously we have on street parking I
will go through the highways issues
later in the
presentation
I just want to uh point out as well the
there is the time and date stamp on the
video and this was taken uh around
quarter past 5 um on a weekday um but
appreciate there obviously only a very
small snapshot of the uh the the traffic
situation um but uh as I cover relation
in the presentation there has been
extensive transport and traffic
information submitted by the applic
applicants um which suff County Council
have Ed so now we're just traveling
north up burst or Lane we have the
existing allotments here on the right
you can't quite see from this
angle and then we have the application
site just appearing here on the right
now as we go past the 40 mph speed limit
signs just want to draw members
attention you can see the uh topography
here the uh Road the land OB see is
Raising in level as we come out of the
gipping
valley
appreciate this video is a bit dark but
uh the fourth video shows the site in a
slightly lighter context which will'll
see in a
second there's footpath nine sign on the
right of the screen
there and the house we can just see at
the top of the site there is the
furs
there we go and we'll just go on to
video four
now so we have got the Furs on the left
and we are just traveling down now and
you can see the uh
site uh which we will reach when we get
to footpath nine
sign that just gives you a bit of a a
view of the Topography of the site as
well so here's the footpath N9 sign
coming up on the left here here so this
is where the extent of uh the
application starts on the left
here you can see a mature Tree on the
left hand side there which is proposed
to be retained adjacent to the
allotments and existing residen is there
to the right hand side the south side of
burto
Lane
right now we're just going to run
through some of the photos um there are
a number of viewpoints which members
will hopefully have seen from the
virtual site visit um we're just going
to run clockwise around the site
starting in the Village Center and then
uh moving around the site with some
videos and some photos so just showing
the photos on Lower Street um one a isly
looking up lower Street where we just
have the video and we've got the won
public house there's a mixture of photos
um hopefully in this presentation which
show recent photos in summer but also as
you see from the top right hand corner
there's some photos that were taking in
2019 which uh we're taking March 2019
which just showed the site with less
vegetation just hopefully give members a
all around view of the site at different
states stages of the year so we have the
allotments here see in
Spring and now we're looking at
viewpoint two you can just see the photo
positions in the center of the slide
there I won't linger too long where
we've had recent videos footage and here
we are looking across the site from
view2 this is a video I'm just going to
play Viewpoint 3 is the public foot path
just doing a full 360°
spin that's the foot path
location and just looking down sou the
Caravan storage and the
allotments
Lan and then this is an early photo
taken in 2019 uh just go looking South
down bural Lane um showing some um
previously removed vegetation along that
boundary there I will go through the
Landscaping proposals later in the
presentation but also I just wanted to
point out that you can faintly see the
church um sporton uh church just um here
it's a little bit faint I appreciate um
and it is uh more covered by uh
vegetation trees in the summer months
but just want to point out that is
there's a visibility of that
there and then we're just looking from
Viewpoint 4 a this is just taken next to
the Furs you can just see the fence on
the bottom photo there so we're looking
across the site you can see the land
drop so you can't see all of the site as
the land drops down uh the white
building there on the bottom photo is
obviously the Lor building in sporton
Enterprise Park
and here we are just slightly further
down Viewpoint 4B so not quite on foot
path 9 yet but it's again just showing
the site um kind of uh the Topography is
the site slopes down the top photo there
we've got the grindle um house the white
building just the left hand side of that
photo and the Caravan storage uh which
are the white features just on the right
hand side of that
photo and just swinging back around from
Viewpoint 4B uh we've just got the Furs
and property Dean which the uh neighbors
to the north of the
site okay so now we're just mooving to
Viewpoint five so we're on foot path 9
and we're just looking down towards uh
the well uh northwest corner of the site
and again the right hand photo just
shows that uh visibility there of the
grindle
house and looking swinging around from
view. five uh we've got Caravan storage
on the left photo and just on the right
photo there just want to point out
there's two t tall trees and quite
useful reference points in the landscape
because they're to the rear of the
Wildman Public House and next to the
allotment so that kind of gives you the
indication of the position of the
Wildman Public House listed building
when you look at the remainder of these
photos uh this is just a photo taken
earlier in um 2019 you can see the Lori
building still under construction on the
right hand side of the photo there again
it's just to show the landscape in a
more winter setting rather than the more
leafy summer
setting and just a close up there just
showing uh the historic um core of spon
we have spon Hall uh the red tiled white
building roof on the left at the screen
there uh Community see tithe barn and
again the the church is behind uh the
vegetation so it's slightly harder to
see in that picture there but it is
behind those
trees so we just have a quick video of
view point 6 which is the North West
corner of the
site
showing those two trees there show
the man that shows that sloping site
that we have
there that's the location of foot path
nine it exits the site
Northwest okay now we have a video taken
from the grindle so this uh is with the
grindle house listed building um behind
me here just going to do a 180° spin of
the
camera BL
B one
second
here we
go the video is little bit Judy but it's
just to give the
uh just to give the uh I'm not sure if
that's working for members it's looking
a bit um chaotic that video for me but
it's to try and demonstrate the uh
extent of vegetation along the grin
there um see if that will play again a
bit better there we go
um there a slight change in land level
with the grinder Wing lower than the the
application site so quite vegetation
along that boundary those two features
out okay so now we're on the rainway
we're just going to look at the
viewpoints uh down the rainway back to
the Village Center here we are on the uh
east side of Lorraine way opposite the
application site just looking towards
brownford and across towards the uh
River
gipping starting on the left hand side
photo we're looking back down towards
the uh village sporton Village here the
middle photo uh it's into the
application site you can see the uh
sloping application site in the center
of that photo there and on the right
hand side you have the
grindle um Viewpoint 88b uh just to show
members you may recall uh the
application site on the east side of
Lorraine way uh which members refused
application 49 dwellings which is
currently going through appeal that's
just the application site you can just
see um from this Viewpoint
here and then um right hand side is
looking back down towards
spon here we have the Caravan storage uh
which you may have seen from the videos
earlier and just looking North back
towards Branford and the location of the
60 MPH speed limit National speed limit
it's just a couple of photos within the
site now um just to show uh visibility
uh from view. 10 a the center photo
shows those two trees which I pointed
out earlier obviously the rear of uh the
Wildman Public House and the photo on
the right just looks uh to the northwest
of the site from that
position and here's a photo taken earli
in 2019 19 again just showing the site
without the obviously the trees in leaf
just showing a bit more visibility there
obviously of the Wildman public
house so just taken slightly higher up
the field you can just see the Loria
building uh just uh in the center of the
photo on the left hand side
there and now we're just moving back
toward Village Cent we've got the
existing field access of Lorraine way
into the uh application site um and the
road to the north towards
brownford so we're back towards the
village uh Center now um and the
crossroads Wildman Public House and the
bottom photo just shows the uh the car
park of the Wildman public
house and there we go you can just see
this is the view from within the car
park of the wman public house so just
one final video now this is the junction
of fir B
Lane
okay that's see you get into the photos
and the videos I'm now going to run
through the proposals um obviously
application is in outline but there are
a number of plans submitted to support
the indicative uh information um with
the application so here we have the site
um outlined in red um with the land
within the applicant's ownership within
blue the application is submitted by
pigeon Investment Management on behalf
of the Phoenix Thornley Cobalt
agricultural trust who own this
land here we have the proposed site
layout imposed on the AAL view um I will
go into more detail of this um but here
you can see the access road driveling
through the center of the
site I will go through in more detail in
the future slides but just want to
introduce the uh extent of the proposals
in The Wider landscape
here now um just to uh highlight to
members the previous scheme uh was
submitted as shown on the slide here um
I just want to point out just that are
some comments uh obviously raising
representations about moving of
allotments and a Cricut pitch and an
office and Nursery um the Cricut pitch
proposal um has been removed the
allotments are being retained in situ
now they're not being proposed to be
removed moved further to the west of the
site and uh the site has uh been
rearranged and the office D1 Nursery use
is now proposed to be a community office
or retail space um just to fade through
to the new proposals if I just leave the
previous ones on the screen there you
can see the uh proposed development has
been brought back down to the uh east of
the site uh the previous proposals for
self- build uh further along bural Lane
and Caravan storage um along Bal Lane
that has been removed the application
site is now um much located uh to the
east on the lower land levels the
application it came in 2019 um and after
the original uh consultation went
through the applicants did work with the
uh Parish Council and local community to
try and respond to the concerns raised
which resulted in the allotments being
retained in situ um changes to the uh no
Cricket uh pitch because it was
considered by the community that wasn't
necessarily something that was needed um
and the removal of the proposed
development uh further to the east of
the site um I will show you shortly
where the relocated Caravan storage is
but obviously it's now all much further
uh closer to the uh main
village so I just want to go through the
uh nature of the outline and the full
proposals now so hopefully members um
can see that in detail just going to
show the accesses which are proposed um
in the outline so all matters are
reserved except for Access access is
being applied for so we have burst or
Lane we have an access point to the
south of site here and realignment of
that road which I'll go to a bit more
detail shortly we have access on the
rainway we have access for the Caravan
storage which I'll will show you is
located here on the parameter plan
shortly but access here for that um
storage use only and then accesses for
the self-built plots on versal Lane
here the parameter plan I'll break this
down and go through a little bit more
detail but there is a parameter plan
submitted with the application and um if
the recommendation is accepted the
development would be approved to be
broadly in in Broad accordance with this
parameter plan because it has been
carefully designed to respond to the
constraints of the uh surrounding site
the landscape and the Heritage um
historic
assets so just to pull this apart
slightly we've got the extent of the
full application the full application is
shown in this uh blue color and the um
slightly uh Dusky green color
the full application covers the spine
road which is just shown through the
site here this location of these roads
here is being applied for in full and
would be fixed by this
application uh and also the um the suds
feature which supports that uh that road
obviously we need to make sure that the
surface water from that road can drain
into that Subs feature so those two
components are part of the full
application the remainder are outlined
so I'll just run through those now we
have self- bu plots in two locations and
we have four here shown in
pink uh SS and open space shown in
green relocated Caravan storage which is
currently um just under where the suds
and open space uh note is the green area
that's being relocated to this uh
hatched area
here we've got retained paddocks they
will stay there and we have in light
blue a safeguarded uh land for a
potential future relief Road um this was
uh something which uh was uh raised
through the uh previous
consultation um and as a potential
should land to the south of this
application site ever come forwards uh
the applicants have intended to
safeguard um a route through this
application site so that a uh a form of
a relief Road from the historic core of
sporton to avoid traffic moving through
um sporton could be um implemented in
future so they're not proposing to
implement it obviously as land to the
South which would be required to connect
to make the relief Road functional it's
not available it's not being promoted as
such but to prevent any future such
relief Road from coming forwards um to
avoid it being prevented uh the
applicants have ensured that the land is
safeguarded and would not be uh
developed so it is a it's just a
safeguarding uh point at the
moment so just looking at the center of
the parameter plan we've got see the
spine Road the orange uh land is
identified as a community um office or
local shop use it is land that is being
um promoted as such and it would be
secured um in a section 106 agreement
for a period of time to see whether a
use could come
forwards we've got a village car park so
that's just uh to the north of the
existing allotments and and connected by
foot paths to the main village and I'll
go into the uh zebra Crossing and other
Highway features in latest slides to
ensure they've got safe pedestrian
connectivity uh SS an open space
paddocks which is shown in the green
color and just looking at the south of
the parameters plan we've got the an
extension to the existing allotments of
.4 hectares and we've got the remaining
nine self-build plots uh to the south of
site uh just to go through the access
Arrangements um I just want to show how
um cars would move through the site with
the proposed changes um so for uh
vehicles to go from uh bural Lane um bur
Lane to Lorraine way through the
application side um the Red Dot will
just show the route
through and uh the uh traffic modeling
submitted with the application indicate
that uh 30% of the traffic uh traveling
East along uh bural Lane uh towards the
Wildman Public House they do actually
travel North to brownford and so uh it's
been modeled that around 33% of traffic
that currently uses the junction
possibly at uh um wildan Public House
could end up using the spal through the
site so would in effect provide some
relief uh for the um existing Junction
at Wildman public house um Al obviously
people can still travel uh down bural
Lane to the High Street as this route
shows that will still remain open uh but
obviously if there's an alternative
Junction that potentially is uh less uh
trafficked um with less um obviously
doesn't have a Crossroads uh with the
lower Street then it may be that
people's habits will dictate that they
will use the spine to try and alleviate
the pressure on the junction So that
obviously is a opportunity and a
potential benefit um for of the
scheme and just to show the access into
Lorraine way into the community car park
would be there and access for the
Caravan storage would be in that
location okay so I just want to go
through some of the other Highway
improvements um that are proposed with
the application there have been
extensive discussions with the Highway
authority to consider how the highway
impacts could be mitigated but also how
further enhancements could be made um to
the Village of sport and from this
scheme uh this shows the access and
Lorraine way um we've got a a footway
cycle way which is proposed um that uh
will come through the site and then to a
pedestrian Crossing on the road here I
will show um slightly more um detailed
information in the LGH SL later slide on
this one but also so just shown in brown
here we have a raised table um integ
block which is a obviously a slight
traffic caling feature through the site
just to obviously uh slow the traffic
down as we come to this Junction and the
connection um with the community use
which is to the south of the
slide so here we have the highway
Improvement works on Lorraine way the
access into the site would be a
formation of a right hand turn um land
just shown in the center of the slide
here that's the footway cycle wave that
I referred to going to The Pedestrian
Refuge which just highlighted an orange
there which would create um a Crossing
points to the um east side of Lorraine
way and also uh weight restriction
signage is being um relocated to here
and also on bursal Lane just to make
sure that uh um no um heavy lorries can
use the spine row to access bural Lane
where there is a weight restriction
existing weight
restriction so this is on burst or Lane
we've got the um New Junction
Arrangement here so existing burst or
Lane runs along the uh red line but it's
proposed to realign this Junction uh to
try and divert the traffic try and
divert pressure away from uh the wild
man Crossroads uh as previously
mentioned while still maintaining that
this road is
open uh again we've got some uh surface
features uh Road materials shown here
and that's the other weight restriction
signage that I referred to
earlier
the AL also Highway improvements being
secured um we're now looking at the uh
so we've got the Wildman Public House V
pretty much in the blue area here with
the lower Street to the bottom right of
the slide uh we've got a proposed bus
shelter relocated bus stop the bus stop
is currently outside the wildine public
house so just kind of putting it further
north but just to kind of move it away
from the heavily trafficked area of that
Junction um but also to enable uh zebra
Crossing to come forwards
um through uh this
scheme and that's just a footway which I
referred to earlier which would enable
access to the proposed Village car park
allotments community shop and obviously
the remainder of the residential and the
public rights of way connections that
the site has which are shown as the
moment uh this is the Wildman uh Public
House Junction just to show some changes
to uh surface uh treatment and
realignment which would be secured uh
through section 106 contributions and
planning
condition just to give uh some wider
Highway improvements as well we've got
uh the improved Junction which I just
showed you bural Lane High Street uh
relocated 30 m now speed limit this
would go further to the north um of the
application site than it is currently
located and new or refreshed Village
Gateway signs indicated at the numbers 1
three four and five on the plans
there and finally on the highways um
members may recall with the Hopkins home
site uh um to the east of the site there
was a wider cumulative Highway
assessment work which was undertaken in
2019 to consider the applications that
were coming forwards in this area um and
to do uh to consider and mitigate the
impacts this table at the bottom right
hand corner here um there's a series of
four Works um to the B1 1113 um the
bagle roundabout and a proposed cycle
link on sport between Sport and
brownford off all of which this
application site would uh deliver uh
proportionate funding through section
106 agreement um so the highway works
could all be delivered um members may
recall obviously the uh refuse scheme of
Hopkins homes was contributing to this
um it's noted that this scheme is
refused and the applicants have um
agreed to fund the contribution that
Hopkins homes would have made um should
the um site not come forward so the
appeal is um dismissed
so we've got certainty still there would
be sufficient funding with all of these
sites coming forward to deliver those
wider Highway improvements as
well so just moving on to the final few
details um with the application we've
got um indicative uh affordable housing
plan it's obviously outlined at present
so we don't know precisely the final
number of houses which will be proposed
and their positioning but the applicants
have demonstrated that there could be um
obviously um a good mix and a dispersal
dispersal dispersal of um affordable
houses throughout the development the
affordable housing mix um is acceptable
it contains six bungal um we will secure
no more than ensure there's a cluster of
no more than 15 in any one location
through the section 106 agreement um it
will it be ensured that the uh buildings
are tene blind so there's no distinction
between market and affordable dwellings
at the reserve matters stage um but uh
uh officers are content that it's
perfectly feasible that the an approach
at um affordable housing uh mix could be
secured to the section 106 agreement at
the reserve matters
stage just running through the
Landscaping plan now um the applicants
have uh worked quite extensively to try
and ensure that this is a very green
development and that there is space for
landscaping um and good quality
Landscaping within the development and
also through the provision of public
open space so just to point out on these
plans I've just shown where the existing
Woodland is at present and the retained
gray to agricultural land shown there by
the uh uh greeny Brown
field the proposals include a community
Woodland that would be secured through a
section 106 agreement to ensure its
delivery and uh future management that's
located here there would be um
connections uh footpath connections to
this community Woodland to ensure the
residents of the proposed development
and also um hopefully the wider Village
can have good access to this there would
be new foot paths through the community
Woodland that would be secured and a new
connection to footpath 9 which runs
along the uh uh left hand side of the
slide here so creating good public uh
rights of way and green infrastructure
connections to The Wider
Countryside you can also see from this
slide uh there's uh much additional
planting I will show some uh Street scen
visualizations in a moment of the
Landscaping um as it
matures um additional planting also to
to the west of the site here um and
along the proposed paddocks in the field
here um and also throughout the site I
think it's it's quite important also to
show that there is space for trees
within this development um within the
spine Road um space has been left for
not only the road but also um a
pedestrian and cycle footway along the
south of the uh road which I'll show
shortly and and also Landscaping because
it really is important to make sure at
this stage although it's only outlined
but that we do have have space for the
Quantum of development and the level of
landscaping needed to make sure that we
can get a good quality design in
future just showing the
paddock and here's the Street Scenes
that um I referred to earlier so in the
bottom left hand side of the screen here
you can see where the street scenes are
taken from so the top one a is taken
from within the site um and it's showing
the potential community building which
would be restricted to one and a half
stories and um proposed development um
residential development in the site the
two bottom um cross-sections are taken
from Lorraine way and they show um the
development um at 5 years after
completion after planting and then once
planting matures and it's to show that
uh there is space and um proposed
Landscaping which will be secured um
through the um planning conditions to be
implemented um that we can really soften
the appearance of this development and
provide some um um good screening and
just make sure that there's no kind of
Stark uh development appearance along
the
rainway so also uh just looking uh from
the east side of the site again we've
got uh section see at the top is taken
adjacent to the proposed development so
you can see the uh changing land levels
there uh and also the indicative
development but as we step back from the
other side of the paddocks you can see
the proposed landscape escaping on the
east side of the paddock and when that
matures in that bottom cross- section
there just showing that uh the uh the
view although slightly further back when
you look from footpath nine will be of
mature Landscaping rather than again
Stark uh fences or um houses which we
wouldn't want to uh
have and then one final cross-section
here we've just got this one if you've
got your backs to the allotments looking
um looking to the north along the south
of the site um we've got uh oh sorry
that's the wrong visualization sorry
members I'm going to have to skip that
that's the visualization we've just
looked at for the community building on
the uh on the east of the site we we uh
we will move on from that
one so um I'll come to the planning
balance now um I'm just going to run
through the key issues and just going
little bit more detail about the um
harms of the scheme and then look at the
benefits of the scheme before I conclude
on the um
application so the key issues which
members will note from the conclusion of
the committee report is obviously this
application is um the site is outside
the builtup area boundary I think
members all know that obviously that's
conflict uh there's conflict with policy
CS2 of the course strategy but that is a
policy which we do have to give slightly
less weight to due to its um age and
consistency inconsistency within
nppf um local housing need you may have
seen in the report that uh we had uh a
local housing needs assessments
submitted with the application
unfortunately this didn't fully meet the
requirements of cs11 and so we have to
say we have to note that there still is
some tension with this policy with cs11
with regards to housing need the
indicative mix of the proposed
development does respond well to the
identified needs and our strategic
housing market assessment so the
majority of houses are two and three
bedroom that's something that we can
secure through planning condition um to
make sure that that uh mix um broadly
comes forward at Reserve matter stage um
subject to obviously enabling the
applicants um to justify if
otherwise um and also the affordable
housing the is policy compliant 35% and
the housing mix is um exactly what is um
required by our strategic housing team
they are happy with the housing mix and
so the application does respond to local
housing needs to a degree but we can't
say that we have a full um assessment
that we are content with it demonstrates
that there is a local housing need for
uh this development in terms of Cs 11 of
the core strategy um I will come on to
um how we bounce that out shortly
obviously that is a conflict um of this
scheme we also have some landscape
impacts you'll seen from those slides
that there is um a significant amount of
landscaping proposed with the scheme but
you can't get away from the fact that at
the moment there is an agricultural
field and the character of that field
will change and there will be some
visual impacts from the development um I
will just go through the uh impacts in
in in the slid shortly but finally the
Heritage impact is the key um matter
that I want to uh go through with
members we've got two key um issues with
the Heritage impact the Wildman public
house um of officers and uh the
council's Heritage officer of the
opinion that with the um proposed uh
development it's unlikely this would
lead to um a significant level of harm
to the wild man public house um
obviously setting of listed buildings
it's not just whether development can be
seen from the listed building it's about
how the listed building uh relates to
its surrounding landscape and certainly
um the wildan public house um whilst
noting there would be a degree of harm
with development um you know kind of
behind where it's historically been on
the edge of the village it's not
considered this would lead to a
significant level of harm because of the
nature of the public house it doesn't
relate to the site as much as the
grindle house and the historic core of
spron so the grindle house uh We've
noted that there could be be a low to
medium level of less than substantial
harm um but as you'll notice from the
tabled papers there is a real potential
for that to reduce with the
establishment of the community Woodland
now um we've advised members to consider
the worst case scenario that there could
be a medium level of less than
substantial harm because at present we
don't have final details of that
Community wooden planting and obviously
if um if the trees um aren't sufficient
enough then that level of harm um could
stay at medium but there's every
Prospect um our Council the council
Heritage officer considers that that
level of harm could be reduced from low
to even negligible if there's a good uh
mature uh planting scheme for that
Community
Woodland the historic core of sporton as
I call it um is a collection of listed
buildings so the church uh sporton Hall
uh the mill buildings tithe barn and the
um root Barn um there would be a low
than uh low level of less than
substantial harm to the setting of these
historic attics which function obviously
um perhaps there's a group within the
village of uh historic um interest um
but this harm also has potential to
reduce to a negligible with the final
details of the scheme so the ridge
Heights of the building if they're kept
to a sufficiently low level then the
harm could be uh negligible but again we
don't have the final details to be able
to really eradicate that harm at present
so we're advising members to base the
recommendation on the low level of um
less than substantial
harm so moving on to um the benefits uh
obviously the site is located in a
fairly sustainable location compared to
other sites within the district it does
have good accessibility and connections
uh to IP switch and it is in close
proximity obviously reducing the need to
travel to key Services compared to um
other locations within the district it
would also deliver Market housing policy
compliant affordable housing levels and
also self-build which is quite um
obviously an important uh factor for the
council we do have a waiting list of uh
over 300 people on the self-build
register and this could help deliver um
self- Buu plots for people on that
register uh the scheme is predominantly
two three bedroom homes its indicative
mix as I mentioned that could be secured
through condition to try and give some
certainty over the reserve matters uh
Community Woodland is proposed which is
a significant benefit providing
recreational access and public rights of
way for existing and future residents we
have an extension to the aot
uh the numerous Highway improvements
which I listed earlier in the
presentation uh Village car park and
also the applicants have demonstrated
that there would be a biodiversity net
gain to this application site uh from
taking um a relatively obviously farmed
agricultural field which obviously has
uh um some ecological benefits but
really improving those ecological
benefits through the um planting and
mitigation measures um which are
detailed in the ecological reports
submitted with the application and it
would demonstrate an improvement and a
net gain over the existing situation on
the site there's also a number of
measures of sustainable construction
which the applicants have set out which
are detailed in the committee report
which would also um be of benefit and
although outlin stage do give an
indication of what can be approved at
the reserve
matters so we'll go I'll go through the
uh the harms just slightly more um in
the following slides but I just want to
bear in mind obviously that uh whilst
the council has a 5-year land Supply
which is recently been reinforced with
the publication yesterday of the um land
Supply position uh we do need to ensure
that we boost our supply of housing with
the right sites in the right locations
uh it's not something U that we can
necessarily
um sit back on and refuse once we have
land Supply recent appeal decisions have
shown for significant schemes that even
in the presence of a land Supply we do
still need to consider is this the right
location for additional housing to boost
that land Supply um and obviously from
the recommendations um officers have
made we considered that it
is so just to show the uh Heritage
harm um in a bit more detail we have the
uh The grindle Farmhouse it is um
obviously a Heritage asset and any harm
to that asset must be given utmost
important but I just want to draw some
distinction perhaps from the um historic
core the historic core obiously have a
series of listed buildings um including
um grade um one listed building um which
is Al grade two star listed building of
the church um which obviously gives it
quite significant Heritage importance um
there is a slightly higher level of less
than substantial harm to The grindle
Farmhouse but that is um only one listed
building and so the the kind of overall
context of the harm perhaps is lower
than if we had a medium level of less
and substantial harm to that historic
core so I think uh the the level of harm
of this scheme um is perhaps a slightly
a different situation to the appealed
site um over the road um on the Hopkins
site on land to the east of Lorraine way
but this is a different scheme in a
different context the benefits the
public benefits of this scheme are in a
very different magnitude to um other
application sites but we must consider
this on its own merits in isolation um
and the public benefits of the community
Woodland the um 37 affordable housing um
the extension to the allotments Village
car park and the highway improvements
that have um hopeful benefit to existing
residents not just to mitigate the
impact of this development they all
weigh um in favor of um balancing out
that medium level of less and
substantial harm to The grindle
Farmhouse and the low level of harm to
the historic core um of spron Village um
also again I'll draw members um Minds to
the fact that there is potential as well
to reduce that level of harm this is an
outline scheme and with those final
details my Heritage officer you know has
indicated that there's every likelihood
those level of harms could be brought
down to low levels of harm or even
negligible harm with those final details
that does give officer some comfort as
well that this could be um much less
harmful scheme once we have the uh the
details at the reserve matters
stage the sorry let's go to the next
Slide the landscape impact to just show
the uh special landscape area can I just
interrupt you there Joe I'm very sorry
to do this but I see canor hinton's
Hands been up a little while I don't
know if on a point of order or what um
if it's that I have to take a bit if
it's not then I'll ask no Mr chairman
just waiting so that I could come in on
the questions at the end oh right that's
fine that's fine thank you sorry Joe
carry on that's okay no
problem so the landscape impact um as
you note from the report um the
landscape impacts and visual effects are
noted to be moderate to slight adverse
um but they would be reduced over time
with the proposed Landscaping that has
come in now I know that landscape impact
is a matter which has been raised
extensively in the representations of
the scheme and there is no escaping the
fact that any development on this site
would lead to an impact on the uh
landscape and the special landscape area
but through the work that has been
carried out through the landscape visual
impact assessment those heart can be um
significantly um moderated and mitigated
by the planting that is proposed and
they really do only bring the they bring
the harms down to slight adverse impact
so that's something which hopefully can
give members comfort in the um the
overall harms of the
scheme I'm just showing the uh
Landscaping there on that
slide and that's just obviously to
recall the uh the uh Landscaping that is
proposed but I've gone through those
slides in detail so I won't uh dwell in
too further so just to draw it all
together now um in summary um I just
want to kind of highlight the harms of
the scheme which hopefully I've I've
gone through in sufficient detail to
give members a clear understanding of
those of the site being outside the
builtup um settlement boundary the
Heritage harm Which is less than
substantial which has been weighed
against the uh public benefits um the
landscape harm and the loss of gr three
agricultural land although it's not
certain whether it's grade 3 A or B um
ass Soul testing hasn't been carried out
but there is the potential for the loss
of 3A which is classed best most
versatile agricultural
land in uh um and in summary on the
benefits um I've just listed those on
the right hand side of the screen there
I have gone through those in the
previous slide so perhaps won't say them
all out loud again but uh we do have
obviously extensive benefits and public
benefits too um to make a benefit to
Future residents and hopefully existing
residents of spaen
um through public rights of way the
allotment extensions um Highway
improvements for pedestrians and
cyclists um and so the benefits of the
scheme are considered to be um
significant and compelling in this
instance um it's noted obviously that
there is a high level of um opposition
to the scheme with over 300 letters
objection and it is something that I've
discussed extensively with the parish
council as have the applicants to try
and address the concerns in so far as
possible but the um the planning balance
for this application is that whilst
there are some harms those benefits um
they do outweigh and the public benefits
in particular outweigh the Heritage
Harms in officers
opinion so just to summarize the
conclusions um obviously uh we've got
the conflict um with core strategy as
CS2 and there's some tension with con as
uh policy cs1 because the local housing
need issue but the proposals are
considered to comply with cs1 and CS s
15 with the core strategy for
sustainable development uh we've got
Heritage and Landscape impact but we
consider them to be outweighed by the
public benefits and this is a
sustainable location where we consider
that the addition of housing of this
Quantum um provides um obviously a good
site to boost our land Supply which is a
requirement of the from the
mppf uh the benefits are considered to
be significant and compelling there are
a number for this scheme and it is
something which I hope um whilst sporten
Parish Council and other um objetives
have noted um their they remain opposed
to the scheme it has been engagement
with the local community to try and
modify the scheme to address some of
those concerns from the previous um and
originally submitted
application so this would boost the
supply of our housing and particularly
with two three bedroom dwellings which
cured by condition and the provision of
self-build all highways uh
infrastructure and highways matters are
addressed there's no evidence before
officers to say that there is any um
adverse impact to education capacity to
doctor's capacity doctor surgery
capacity um uh contributions are being
secured and still um a bids could be
made to adequately address all of those
matters and the scheme has been
considered in accumulation in terms of
Highways and Landscape U and
infrastructure um with all other schemes
that are consented in the area and there
are no harms which uh lead officers to
recommend refusal of the scheme on that
basis so on balance um this is
considered to be a deliverable um
sustainable development and officers
recommend uh permission is granted as
detailed in the tabled
papers thank you chair uh thank you very
much um case officer Joe Hobs I think
you've um put forward a very good and
full report very clear and very detailed
I can see you spent a lot of time on it
and that's very helpful um before I just
go to John can I just ask one point
which you could perhaps clarify time we
are now ask them for questions of
clarifications or that um the
the last uh few meetings that the um
District Council have had we've been
surprised at some of the indicative
plans that have been shown at this early
stage at outlining and then when it gets
to detail it Alters
considerably uh mix uh pepper popping uh
Road layouts even construction footpath
have you you taken this on board in this
I think you did say that um we picked
this up at this outline uh but can you
just explain that please to
us yeah certainly yeah so obviously
outline consent um it is indicative the
plans are submitted but this application
has G gone into a fair amount of detail
to demonstrate how it can address the um
potential harms to Heritage and
Landscapes and such like uh the
parameters plan um which I I could skim
back to you but it's further back in the
presentation but parameters plan would
be fixed um um that the development
should be broadly in compliance with the
parameters plan to ensure the
development comes forward in those
locations um and the spine Road in this
instance is fixed and so that road would
be um delivered as shown um in the plans
now the um other information such as uh
the um location of the affordable
housing and the housing mix that is
obviously something which we do need to
give some flexibility to because this is
outline stage only but with the
affordable housing there would be a
clause in the section 106 to ensure that
there's clusters of no more than 15
dwellings which would lead to three
locations um at least in this
development obviously we've got 37
dwellings and uh we do have a condition
on the uh Market housing mix um which um
offs are happy to um include shell
predominantly be two and three bedroom
but also we need to obviously um respond
to any evidence on housing need at the
time so if there's any refresh of the
Strategic housing market assessment we
would request the applicants reflect on
this um and obviously um we can agree a
um a mix on that but we would um we
would be looking to try and have a mix
broadly in line with what's shown at
this stage unless the applicants can
give a reasons justification as to why
it needs to be different thank you in
our legal um lawyer did you want to
comment on that yes if I may just come
in chairman I'll make myself visible for
a moment and I must apologize to my
colleague Mrs Hobs I I ought to about
this before the meeting but I'll just on
the self-build housing Joe um I've not
I've just trying to read things on one
screen I've only got one screen here so
I'm sorry if this point ought to be
obvious to me but we you have quite
rightly advised members that the um the
presence of self-building housing as a
component of this proposal uh mer merits
is a there's a material consideration
and Fa that because of government policy
and national government policy and
indeed legislation but I just wonder if
you could advise I specifically on the
extent to which that is um guaranteed of
the the self-built houses are guaranteed
as of delivery um with by condition um
because I'm just thinking that um as as
we both
know self-build housing isn't a used
Class in itself it's a self-build house
is a C3 so in the absence of a condition
a self-build house an intended
self-built house can become a if you
like a market and for once of a better
word a normal house if you forgive me
using that word um so would is it may I
ask that question um I that there is a
reference I saw there was a reference to
a requirement to Market them in the
right places but would would would you
be able to comment further on that
please yes I think um yeah I um you
point out um a valid point there that
obviously um we we will try to ensure
that uh people on our self build reg to
have the opportunity to take up these
plots but obviously we can't insist that
they do come forward to self bu so
whilst we have every hope that um they
they would be taken up by the 300 plus
people on um the self build register um
there is a chance obviously that they
could come forwards as um private Market
dwellings in future um obviously that
wouldn't be in accordance with the
parameter plan it may be something that
we need to um seek any future landown to
regularize at future date um uh they
need to come forwards further but yeah
we can't necessarily insist on it um but
my experience is hopefully that um self
bir is is quite a popular concept um but
yeah we do need to advise members that
there is a chance that they may not come
forward and we cannot insist on that a
condition stage for sure thank you thank
you I thought that was the case thank
you that was very helpful right we're
now members at the point of
clarification by the C officer I've got
councelor Hinton followed by councelor
Osborne so councelor Hinton questions
thank you thank you Mr chairman uh just
a a couple of um couple of points really
uh I was going to mention the
the requirements of cs11 but that has
come up uh and I'm sure it will come up
again in the debate uh but we're looking
at an application here which is for
basically permission to build on a field
and the roads being fixed but everything
else is up in the air or controlled by
106 or
conditions um having numerous conditions
obviously does make things confusing for
everybody um is there
anything further that we can uh clarify
in terms of what is actually controlled
by this permission we've already heard
that we can hope that the affordable
housing is going to be in certain
positions we can hope that the self
bills are going to be there we can hope
that they're going to be two and three
bedrooms but is what can we do to
actually make sure it actually happens
because with this particular uh
applicant there is a bit of a history
that was uh dealt with in the last uh
couple of meetings uh about uh outline
being one thing and Reserve matters
being something completely different uh
and contrary to what most counselors I
think thought would be possible and the
second point was um looking through the
list of consules I see that uh mids are
consulted and have no comments um with
all the housing they've got just down
the road I'm not surprised uh but what
about ipswitch we keep on saying easy
access into whp switch but uh have they
got any comments on it because obviously
it's going to impact upon them when you
get all the occupants of these houses
potentially decamping into whs each
other for employment Recreation or
shopping or
whatever thank you okay thank
you um yeah to take the questions in
turn the uh yeah this application um
obviously I think it's um we we we can
all learn and reflect from previous
experience can't we as to um what's
happened on other applications um and
this application we do have a very clear
parameters plan which is um which like I
said the development will be broadly in
accordance there'll be conditioned to
ensure that so that gives certainty um
Fair a fair amount of certainty over the
position of different uh components of
the scheme but it really is those
planning conditions that's um that's
what will help ensure that say the
community Woodland comes for as the uh
um the extension to the allotments comes
forwards um we do need to obviously
reflect on um the fact this is outlin
and we can't insist that the housing mix
is as shown in this application but um I
think the conditions that we're
proposing and the um Clauses in the
section 106 when it comes to housing mix
and affordable housing they really will
help um provide more certainty than we
have had on previous recent perhaps
examples of applications because we are
specifying that the housing mix shall be
predominant two and three-bedroom whilst
enabling the applicants to provide a
reasons justification because we do have
to be reasonable we do have to allow the
applicant to demonstrate um if there's a
compelling reason why they can't meet
the precise mix which has been set out
in the outline um but say with the
affordable housing um our affordable
housing um strategic housing team are um
very uh clear that obviously they want
uh development uh affordable housing to
be um integrated well into the existing
uh Housing Development they don't want
it you know one culdesac and one aspect
of the scheme and we do have the Clause
of no more than 15 dwellings and we will
ensure um that the materials um are
tenure blind um as we say to ensure that
the uh there is no distinction between
the quality of the final build of those
units so we do we do have the this a
balancing act of obviously being
reasonable at this outline stage but I
do think the conditions that are
suggested in this um application do give
us um a good degree of control to make
sure that we have uh the aspirations of
this outline scheme reflected when it
comes to the uh the bedroom sizes and
the affordable
housing um with regards to I Swit Bar
Council the um they weren't directly
consulted um on this application um
there is some uh distance perhaps
between the um boundary of this um the
the bar and this site but I do take your
point that um obviously uh this does
lead to a um a Reliance um on a future
demand of services when it comes to um
IP switch um the key matters which I
think we need to um concern ourselves
with are the planning matters um and
when it comes to planning matters we're
also looking at the infrastructure so uh
the highway impact on uh residents of
ipswitch that has been obviously modeled
with the um the background data and the
transport assessment to think about all
the committed developments in the area
to ensure that the uh the roads can
still function highways England
obviously have an interest um with the
A14 um when it comes to other matters
such as services such as um say shops
it's obviously a larger much more of a
commercial um matter so it's not
something that necessarily can concern
ourselves with um or be a reason to
refuse but the key matters relating to
infrastructure um and the potential
pressures on iwit they have have been
considered in this application so I feel
that we've we've done everything that we
reasonably can to ensure that uh there
are no adverse impacts cumulatively with
this scheme or other consented schemes I
hope that answers your question it does
to a certain extent if I may come back
Mr chairman um but what we've also got
to remember is that infrastructure is a
little bit more than
roads um and and access points and also
within the spron parish there are
already nearly a thousand homes being
proposed up at Walley gra so uh the
actual impact on all of the access
points into whip switch and all of the
infrastructure whether it be schools
doctors shops water gas etc etc etc
Broadband all all everything um is going
to be um piling up and we don't seem to
take
uh a hard enough line if you like on
making sure that these things are uh
looked at and considered at an early
enough stage we sort of wait for the
problem to come and then try and sort it
out
afterwards um I don't you clarify that
point
okay right um Ju Just um just follow on
on slightly from what councelor Hinton
said I understand what you're saying
about the mix and and the conditions to
the applicant but if this was s if this
site we were minded to approve it and
this site was then eventually sold to
another uh developer can those
conditions be held to that developer
because this is where we um fell down on
a previous
application um are they strong there as
well thank you chair yes the um housing
Ms condition I have I've considered this
to think obviously what's the uh
potential for condition being appealed
and removed at a later date because you
you want to make sure you've got
certainty and um the housing mix
condition uh that we're proposing and
the requirement for predominantly two
and three bedroom units um that does
reflect the evidence that's in the
Strategic housing market assessment of
what is needed in relation to and
dwelling size in babber um so if uh we
were to have um an appeal to remove the
condition um I do feel that we do have
evidence the council is acting
reasonably asking for um the indicative
mix to include predominantly two and
three bedroom because we do have the
evidence to back that up um so I feel
that um even if someone were to
challenge that um I think we we do have
a good case of uh hopefully um still
having that condition on the on the
dwelling sizes thank you councelor
Osborne you were
next councelor
Osborne you're still
muted you're not there
councelor
Osborne yes thank you Mr chairman I'm
sorry about that my my mouse my mouse
ran
away um yeah the clarification I want i'
got I've got two areas really but um um
first of all at what stage of this
application will the allocation of the
affordable be agreed I.E L uh um local
connection need babber wide Gateway wide
and what input will Ward members have in
this
decision the affordable housing would um
be secured when the reserve matters um
are being designed um that that's when
you know the final number of dwellings
that you can achieve on the site because
obviously this is an outline for up to
105 um there may be further
investigations say only 100 can come
forward so may be 36 um affordables
instead of the 37 so it will be when the
final Reserve matters are designed and
and submitted that's when um we'll know
the um precise uh location mix of the
affordable units um with regard to the
um uh the allocation of forway units
that is controlled through the section
106 agreement um but that is something
which um the Strategic housing team um
obviously work on more um than um than
um we deal with through the application
and that would obviously be once the um
houses are um being constructed and
there's obviously more certainty um but
that is a slightly separate process to
the planning process um so um I don't I
don't honestly can't answer the
involvement of um Ward members within um
that discussion but that's perhaps a
question we can put to the Strategic
housing team that they're not present
here today but outside of this meeting
yeah thank I'm sure councelor I'm sure
councelor Osborne that you could put
that to uh the cabinet member for hen um
better than a lot of us well thank you
Mr chairman but what I would say about
that is that the the local connection
need and you've you've seen it as
chairman on several applications and
that is that uh they need they need the
local uh people to have the access to to
affordable housing and it seems that uh
babber also should have an input into
that and then whatever Gateway and that
Gateway means that they'll be coming in
from every everywhere else except the
local areas so that is my concern and I
understand about the affordable setup of
it however that would be something that
needs to be looked at before we go fur
any further into Reserve matters um
thank I think you I think you've made
your point there I think it's very valid
that we do want local people to have
local houses and I think we need to pick
that up outside the plan and meeting um
had you got another point of
clarification you wanted yeah I'm
just with John hindon thing about
highways c h no I I need questions for
clarification to the
officer well um it appears it appears to
me and she can probably um Joe S of
bigger pardon Joe could uh tell me um
we've got we had these situations around
B Burl and and that area that very thin
Road running down from the Beagle
roundabout um it appears you know has
County Council maybe this should be a
question I ask to council Hudson but um
has has anything been looked at as far
as the congestion that will lead No
Doubt with the other applications that
has been put in there and around there
it it seems you've got one area that
you're you're getting rid of and then
you're doubling it up on on the area
that uh you you just put this uh spine
Road
into yeah the um the highways um
Authority has looked at all the um
committed developments um in the area
with this application but in doing so as
well there are obviously other Highway
improvements in this area associated
with baly Grange one um that are
proposed to come forward um so obviously
yeah the current highway traffic
situation um is one thing but the growth
that has already been consented um has
mitigation measures identified with it
and then along with the mitigation
measures identifi with this application
um it's considered that the the road
Network would function um in an
acceptable way um so I think it's um
it's important to kind of obviously
consider that yes whilst there is quite
a lot of other Development coming
forwards that they also have some
significant mitigation measures to
address their impacts as well yeah the F
the final point about it is you talk
about the weight restriction on on that
road is 115 is it 113
yeah3 yeah sorry about that um how are
you how are you intending to get the
enforcement on that for weight
restrictions because it doesn't work on
other areas so I'd be interested to know
how you're going to enforce
it yes obviously um the existing weight
restriction along bural Lane um is in
place and uh to ensure that no one can
use the spine road to kind of um avoid
the weight restriction signs um or Ural
Lane that's why they're being reloc ated
um um with through this application but
obviously the kind of compliance with
those weight restrictions signs is is a
wider matter um and it's it's there's
other measures there's other um kind of
legislation regulations to in ensure
that that happens that those um um
restrictions are implemented and so it's
not something that perhaps this planning
application could concern itself with
but I do take your point that obviously
your concern over them not being um not
being um enforced but unfortunately um
this planning application it can't um it
can't seek to try and address the any
any wider issue of um enforcement of
other regulations all we can do is
ensure that there is that um kind of
restriction in place to make sure that
we don't have the uh your heavy Vehicles
inappropriately using the site but I do
take your point about the wider issue um
of enforcing these weight limits and
other um Highway matters such as that
with the great dis respect to to you Joe
I you know I understand but wouldn't it
be wouldn't be better for a committee to
to have those put to them at the time
you know this application goes forward I
mean you know I understand you go around
you go around other areas outside the
application however it still needs to be
looked at at the time of an application
going in you you can't tell us what how
you're going to enforce it that to me is
a bit poor but with the greatest respect
to yourself because it's a good
presentation thank you thank I think
she's answered you point I think
counselor Osborne you've got a couple of
questions there to the local County
counselor he might be able to help you
out on that um perhaps you could lower
your hand councelor Osborne and we've
got councelor Barrett next
please thank you chair um Good morning
Joe um I note that on the some of the
objections that have been raised a point
was raised about pollution on the High
Street has that been taken into account
by highways and does it affect this this
site as well and is that is that a
factor in re U the the spine Road
opening out onto Lorraine way to ease
the pressure on that um that Junction by
the the public
house yeah thank you counselor um yeah
the air pollution um is a matter which
are discussed with our Environmental
Protection Team um it's not so much um a
matter uh kind of controlled or
regulated by highways it's more so
Environmental Protection and that is a a
very matter that I discussed with um our
officer in that team because obviously
there are a number of concerns raised
over the air quality in sporton um the
there is routine air quality monitoring
within sporton um and it is well within
acceptable limits at present and there
is no air quality management area as
there is in some other areas of the
district to uh deal with pollution from
nitrous oxide um and other issues uh the
the spine Road um has been designed as
such to try and alleviate pressure on
the Wildman Junction but it's not
essential to um address any air quality
matters um in the area there are not
considered to be any air quality matters
within um current uh regulations and
guidance and our Environmental
Protection officers be that the existing
and proposed
um development um would not lead to any
loss of air quality to an unacceptable
level I hope ansers question yes thank
you thanks thank you can
BBY thank you chair actually I've got a
couple of points about uh the the report
on page
32 right yep uh right at the very bottom
3.52 uh finally lhna does not Etc could
you explain that I don't
understand that paragraph it seems to
come up with a A solution that uh or
conclusion that I would have thought was
the opposite to the right one certainly
I don't suppose you can give me the
paragraph number K you
my2 3.52 thank you just wa me one second
I'm just electronically getting to that
page on my other
computer
3.52 yeah so um 3.52 um it deals with
the submitted local housing needs
assessment um um submitted by the
applicant for the
application um
the yeah the one of the shortfalls of
the um local housing leads assessment is
identify the projected um um households
um modeling different population growth
scenarios but it didn't take account of
the committed Supply um of houses which
the council has already granted planning
permission for which is the point that
we are um we're making in that paragraph
um we we we are just uh basically being
open and honest and clear there with
that statement that the local housing
needs submitted with assessment
submitted with the application doesn't
do the job that it needs to do which is
why I've noted in the conclusion that
we've got that tension with S1 it hasn't
fully demonstrated that there is the um
local housing need um um present um
which this scheme U could respond to so
that's that's that's the whole point of
that paragraph is just saying there is a
flaw with what's been submitted in the
application but then obviously in my um
conclusions and my summary of my
committee report I've um I've addressed
the fact that whil we have that tension
that conflict there are other material
considerations that we consider outweigh
that conflict um and we recommend
approval of the scheme so the
requirement to boost our land Supply
sustainable location um and such like so
that's that's the purpose of that
paragraph in the committee report I did
note um Joe when you were going through
you said
cs11 still some concerns so I think you
did pick that up at that point um you're
you're not saying by that that the that
the identified need from sporton which
was 92 houses hasn't been met by the 505
that Wy Grange have delivered is it
that's not what we saying there is it no
it's not what we're saying no we're just
saying that the applicants haven't
looked at committed Supply yeah right
and the other point I had was that um on
page
36 you don't need to look for this one
Joe it's h it's it's to do with nppf
3.74 it says with the required
compliance with building regulations the
proposed development is considered to
meet the requirements of paragraph 150
of the nppf which seeks to reduce
greenhouse gas emissions just how on
Earth can a a development of a 100
houses
reduce gas
emiss it's the debate perhaps
sustainability versus sustainable
development um with development there is
obviously always going to be um an
environmental impact but what we're
looking to do is to reduce the potential
impact of that development by reducing
the amount of carbon dioxide and
greenhouse gas emissions from the
development compared to what it could be
obviously complete sustainability is the
release of no greenhouse gases and um um
you know kind of um no harm at all but
obviously with development there is
going to be some some um harm arms but
what we're looking at with the proposed
mitigation measures which would be
secured by planning condition is
reducing those harms and keeping the
greenhouse gas um emissions as low as
possible on the
scheme okay so that's what you're saying
it's a misleading statement in the nppf
really I think
mpbf well yeah I mean either we're
trying to reduce greenhouse gas or we're
not if we are then building a 100 houses
to me doesn't seem unless there there
something special about those houses
which is the point I think that the nppf
is trying to make unless there's
something special about the
sustainability of those houses you're
not going to reduce the greenhouse
gas and anyway that that's that's the
questions and great report Joe and I
think you probably deserve a break since
you've talked for an hour and a half
yeah uh I'm going to come to that uh I'm
I'm going to propose we have a a few
minute break after we've done this
clarification part um there's no more
hand up uh nobody else has got any
points of clarification they want to
bring up to Joe I'm assuming no then
because there's nothing up there so
we'll now move to the part which is the
public speakers but I'm going to propose
that we take um a five minute break
which means come back for 11:15 in the
meantime um Robert perhaps you can make
sure that um uh the parish council
represented Helen Davis is with us or
you can updat is uh when we come back at
about quarter 11 okay members so uh a 5
minute break Comfort break and we'll um
pick it up at quarter 11 thank you very
much
brilant thank you chair so I'll just
cond conduct a quick roll call vote to
make sure we're all back from the break
okay so councelor Suz present councelor
Melanie
Barrett come back to councel Barrett
councel beer present Council Busby yeah
back two
seconds counc Hinton
present counc
Jameson come back to him councelor
McLaren present counc Adrian Osborne
present Council Owen present councelor
Parker present and councelor Plum
present so we just go back up the list
then so councelor
Barrett uh counselor
Jameson you can phone both of them while
you I'll give it I'll try again in just
another moment share once
yeah
for
I'll just ask again then chair do we
have councelor Barrett
yes yes I'm here brilliant thank you
councelor and councelor Jameson yep yep
back we're here I now I'm just noticed
chair that the case
officer uh and Mr Russell aren't
here apologies I'm just I've just
messaged
them but
I and just wait for them to rejoin the
meeting
are we supposed to send a quick message
when we're back from our um little no we
did a roll call break oh I missed that
yeah we came back to both you and
councelor
Jameson uh good morning councelor beer
sorry I you lost me for a short while
you may not have noticed but I'm back
now is see uh is M um sorry Mandy we
know I believe we've got Joe back
and Mark brilliant I think we're fine to
carry on chair lovely okay then we're
all present so then we'll move on
members I'll now ask the parish council
representative Howen Davis to speak you
have three minutes in which to address
the committee good
morning thank you chair we object to
this application as have 335 hang on
I'll just sorry can you stop the clock
um we can't hear you can you get over
closer to your mic or turn it
up you just speak I can tell you whether
we can hear
you can you hear me now yes that's
lovely I'm start again I'm punched over
the
screen
okay we object this appication as have
335 of our parishioners plus bur from
elmet and brownford Parish councils
there are a frenzy of applications
coming forward along the gipping
corridor contributing to an almost
continuous ribbon of development along
the B treble 13 they are in addition to
the 1200 Wy Grange homes that build out
of the Old Sugar beat site snow Asis Etc
the new draft jop identifies four
residential sites between spon and
brownford and it looks as though
developers are Keen to get them approved
before the JP comes into effect the
existing adopted local plan policies
should take precedence it should be
noted the emerging jlp allocates only a
small portion of this site for
development with 75 dwellings rather
than the proposed 105 this application
meets minimum planning requirements but
is not exceptional the northern Village
boundary is formed by a collection of
listed buildings all set within a
special landscape area this Heritage
Rich rural Edge is treasured by the
village and has remained untouched for
several hundred years the 2015 Baba
landscape character type report
recommends avoiding development on this
Rolling Valley Farmland which Rises to
35 m above spron it would dominate The
Western Skyline at the Village I.E
principal location harm pigeon have
failed to consider the wider views and
setting of the grade two buildings spren
Hall tie Barn All Saints Parish Church
Etc and their interaction across the
site with the historic listed buildings
in The Wider landscape this site is
encircled with listed buildings and
provides well established views from
bramford to sporton and vice versa
historic England in the setting of
Heritage assets makes clear that having
identified assets affect Ed by a
development and their significance it is
necessary to minimize harm this
development is the opposite it will
cause substantial irreversible impact
harm to the Heritage landscape this
development is outside the village
boundary and will move us one step
closer to emerger with Branford I.E the
creeping coalescence that the nppf
specifically warns against this
application is supported by a housing
needs assessment completed by turly in
June 2020 projected housing needs for
The ipswitch Fringe over the next 16
years have already been approved and are
expected to be built out over the next 5
years if you accept this then it clearly
shows there is no need for further new
housing in spron especially on this
sensitive site traffic volumes along the
B13 are already high just look at the
videos you've seen the assessment is
ignoring the cumulative effects of other
plan developments in bramford Pinewood
cop do cable and great Blum both nppf
and local policies dictate that
development needs to consider provision
of infrastructure in order to be
sustainable SEC strategic planning want
a master plan so cumulative impacts and
needs can be properly assessed this
needs to be done before any more
developments get to go ahead you may
think you've heard this before to a
degree you have this site is beside
Hopkins homes which has already been be
refused twice by yourselves in the
recent past thank
you thank thank you very much um I'll
come to you Joe to comment on some of
what you've heard at the end after I've
asked the members if they've got any
questions for the parish council
Representative members have you any
questions you wish to uh yes councelor
Jameson uh yeah good morning Joe thank
you chair uh so I wanted to clarify are
you saying that you're not happy with
any development in in sporton going
forward and if you are have you got
sites sorry no we're not saying that um
but this site is over going to be
overburdened of development it's too way
too much we've got other site sites
coming forward in our neighborhood plan
um which is reasonably well underway at
the moment and we've also got those 1200
homes approved um well 475 approved at
Wy Grange and a furthest 750 proposed um
as phase two of Wy Grange so there's
already a significant number coming
forward and there's around 83
applications already approved for
dwellings that haven't yet been built
thank you okay thanks um councelor uh
McLaren thank you chair good morning
Helen hello hi um I'm just trying to
clarify how often pigeon
um have consulted either with the parish
or with the village have you has there
been a lot of conversations or has it
just been a one-off meeting
no um they have consulted with us
several times uh the first time was
actually a village exhibition in arai
barn and that was actually done after
they'd first um submitted um to to
babber District Council which was
slightly odd um but since then they have
actually met with us several times and
we've commented on the application so to
be fair it is an improvement on what it
it
was um and they have attended our Parish
Council meetings to see if we've had any
any questions um but you can see from
the number of replies um objections
registered there is um strength strength
of feeling there they have put some
Community things in place which you know
are um you know a good thing to put
forward um but you're not going to get
over 105 developments on a Greenfield
site that's been there for several
hundred many hundred years and is
integral to the way spron sits within
the
valley thank you thank you very much uh
councelor
Parker yeah thank you very much chair
and good morning councelor Davis um you
mentioned there oh sorry forgive me uh
you mentioned just there about your own
neighborhood plan uh at spron now I'm
I'm sure you'll you'll understand that
we can uh we the weight that we can give
to emerging uh plans depends uh upon
where they are in the uh in the system
as it were so can you clarify um
precisely at what technical stage you
are at with your own neighborhood plan
well we've completed our public
exhibition um which happened post the
household survey so we did the household
survey took the results U pulled them
all together and they've gone into the
public exhibition we're now processing
the results of those and we're starting
our first draft and we're beginning to
meet with arrested um land
owners thank
you no more questions is there there's
no hands
up right thank you very much um
councelor Davis from the parish council
uh Joe was there anything you wish to
comment on basically what how D has uh
conveyed to
us um thank you shair now I think um I
think the majority of the issues been
covered in the report and councelor
Parker just picked up the nebor plan
issue um as well so that's fine thank
you lovely thank you very much um right
so we'll now move to we have two
objectors Rona Jermain and Martin Le to
speak um you have one and a half minutes
each I think Rob will uh come in at the
appropriate time and allow the second
person to speak so that's fine if I
could just check because um Mrs German
could you just please confirmed that uh
Mike check has
requested good morning we can hear you
morning everybody which who wishes to go
first just to check ladies first oh
thank you thank you chair that's very
generous um my name is Rona German and
I'm chair of the sport and working group
and we represent the community in
objecting to this application the
planning harm of this and eight more
developments in the F mile Corridor
result in ribbon development along
historic Heritage landscape asset the
gipping valley ultimately spra and will
be absorbed into brownford and this is
to the mppf the Fitzgerald road
development of 195 dwellings in Branford
is only 512 M away from this application
the self-build properties that creep up
the 35 meter Valley side will not
benefit the community and local
government Acres no seal payment for
these 13 self builds they are a cost and
a burden to the infrastructure and
substantial irreversible impact harm to
the Heritage landscape this is the only
development on the west side of the
parish overlooking the exact same
Heritage Village and its assets for
which Hopkins homes was refused from the
top of the site you can see ipswitch
Hospital 4.8 miles away it is the most
elevated site in the parish it holds no
benefit to the existing par parishioners
as it is socially isolated by lineway
elevated position main roads barrier of
the pub allotments and means that social
cohesion will be poor on the indicative
plan the agent has had to admit defeat
in terms of connection and has put the
required suds SP and as a further
barrier the landslope forces this
necessary constraint and results in
disconnection it is outside the existing
Village settlement boundary seeks to
develop well beyond the extremity of the
jlp recommended site by 7.1 hectares it
is the entrance to our village causing
substantial irreversible impact harm to
the Heritage landscape key policies for
your
consideration thank you very thank you
very much thank you thank you Martin
Martin
Le
yes thank you has my image come up yes
yes I can see you we can see you thank
you all right 176 years ago to the day
on the 7th of October 1844 William
woodsworth wrote is there now no Nook of
English ground secure from the rash
assault of development and those Stark
words are a reminder that a planning
committee Remains the last gatekeeper
for a community that it serves about the
future appearances of villages and their
relationship with the surround suring
Countryside the weight of objection in
this case is represented by 335 letters
which oppose the application and the
principal objections that conflicts with
the core strategy policy and it
demonstrates that poor planning
decisions Remain the invisible enemy to
Hinterland Villages the application
conflicts with core strategy on eight
points the site lies within the gipping
valley special landscape area
secondly it's outside the village
settlement boundary thirdly it
concentrates Urban density housing
beyond the core Village and shifts
Highway problems rather than alleviates
them fourthly it causes unnecessary harm
to 13 Heritage assets of which a group
of eight are grade two listed fifthly a
modern development of this size and
scale doesn't harmonize with nor does it
enhance the landscape outside the
village settlement boundary and it RIS
risks coalesence with bramford sixthly
there are no substantial benefits to the
Village to the community or to the
countryside which outweigh the
significant harm caused by the
development seventh a cs1 housing need
doesn't support the application and
eighthly as has been said it's not the
right site nor in the right location
because there are more sustainable sites
as will be identified in the
neighborhood plan thank you thank
you um right uh I'll now
see
um see if there's any questions for the
objectors
members no there none thank you very
much so we can move
on um we don't have a supporter so I now
ask the applicant to speak rob snowling
you so also have three minutes in which
dress the committee and uh if You' like
to start and rub you'll do the timing
thank
you thank you chairman and members for
the opportunity to address you this
morning my name is Rob snowling and I'm
pigeon's associate director with
responsibility for this scheme our
application seeks permission for a high
quality sustainable landscape and design
Leb scheme as described to you in the
case officer's
presentation we've undertaken extensive
engagement in developing the proposals
for L north of bur Lane including a
series of meetings with the parish
council and Sport and work group in
addition to two public exhibitions
following submission of the original
application last
year the amended scheme that is before
members adopts a high quality landscape
Le design approach with extensive areas
of green infrastructure four and a half
hectares in total including a community
Woodland and extensive tree and hedge
roog planting to ensure that the scheme
is a positive addition whilst respecting
and preserving local Heritage
assets responding positively to
community feedback the scheme has been
revised so so that the existing
allotments will be retained in their
current location and enhanced through
the provision of additional plots for
both new and existing
residents the provision of a village car
park next to allotments will provide
additional off street parking which will
be connected to the Village Center via R
new everra Crossing and a 3 meter shared
foot and Cycle Way helping to encourage
sustainable travel the foot and Cycle
Way will form part of a green Corridor
between the rainway to the East and
public footpath 9 to the West which will
provide high levels of connectivity
between the new green infrastructure and
the Village
Center retention of existing boundary
vegitation new planting will ensure that
Wildlife corridors are retained and
enhanced whilst ecological enhancement
such as bat boxes Hedgehog friendly
fencing and log piles will will deliver
an overall net gain for
biodiversity the scheme will also
provide land for Community uses which
will provide new employment
opportunities and widen the range of
services and facilities in the village
in addition to providing energy
efficient homes that will meet
identified needs through the provision
of 37 affordable homes in addition the
provision of 13 self build plots two and
three bedroom Mar Market homes plus 10
Bungalows will meet the needs of both
younger people wishing to stay in the
village as well as the Aging population
and people with access
needs in order to improve the in order
to improve the the local Road Network
the scheme will provide a new Link Road
between the rainway and burst Lan which
will help to ease congestion by
diverting through traffic away from the
wild M Junction whilst also safeguarding
land to facilitate the delivery of a
future relief road to the west of the
village in addition to the off-site
highway improvements has been agreed
with the local Highway Authority a
comprehensive package Village
improvements is proposed these
enhancements will include New Village
Gateway features new speed limits and
weight limit restrictions improvements
to the wild man Junction traffic calming
measures passing Bays on burst Lane and
the provision of a bus shelter on the
rainway in conclusion we acknowledge
that the scheme represents change but
firmly believe that its high quality
landscape Le design provision of new
homes in particular smaller Market homes
and Bungalows extensive public open
space provision together with a
comprehensive package of community
benefits will make a long-lasting
positive addition to the community Comm
of spron thank you for your
consideration I'd be happy to answer any
questions that members may have thank
thank you very much we have questions
from councelor
Hinton thank you Mr chairman uh yes uh
my question really is is uh linked a
little bit to uh previous developments
from your company where you've proposed
in your outline applications
considerable numbers of Bungalows and
then when the the site has been sold on
to somebody else everything seems to
change
within the brocher that you sent round
to everybody you do actually talk about
a significant provision of Bungalows as
part of the scheme's housing mix what do
you regard as
significant so the the the scheme
includes provision of 10 uh Bungalows
within the scheme um so that's that's um
11% of the um of the overall
scheme thank you perhaps next time you
can get a bit closer M if I could come
back Mr chairman y uh you said 11% how
many houses total houses are
there 92 isn't
there can
sites uh I've got down 92 plus 13 self
bu which makes
105 so uh can you hear
us% mind you that's probably just
clarify um the the 11 % sorry is from
from the 92 so it excludes the 13 self
build um for which there isn't a um a
design or a bedroom size that's been
specified as part of part of the scheme
so so yes you're quite you're quite
right um if you take the 10 as as um
proportion of 105 clearly it's not 11%
it would be it would be less thank you
councelor Hinton was that it yeah um
councelor
Barrett thank you ch CH I I was just
going to um raise also the point about
Bungalows um I wondered if there had
been any discussions with the um uh
Village and the the parish about um
single story development and um as as as
we know that is uh very very popular uh
to offer people opportunity to down siiz
um and I think I I thought only six were
in this development but I may be wrong
no there is more right can you answer
that uh Mr
snowland yes of course J um so just to
clar clarify once again um so there are
10 uh Bungalows included within the
overall scheme um of which six of those
will be U affordable um so six
affordable Bungalows uh four Market
Bungalows um and in terms of the
Bungalow provision um yes that that's
something uh through the uh through the
Community engagement that we undertook
um um at say two public exhibitions um
where there was uh support expressed uh
for the provision of Bungalows um within
the scheme um so we sought to respond to
that um with the proposed um housing mix
um that's
proposed thank thank you
question the the the provision of four
seems absolutely minimal and and doesn't
seem to be a good response to um if if
the your engagement with the village was
was meaningful I think you might have
offered more than that
surely can you
comment um yes um so um the uh the
requirement for uh the Bungalows has
been driven to some extent by the
affordable housing requirement so um we
we felt that the provision of 10
Bungalows um was a suitable response to
the requirement for that type of
accommodation um within within the
scheme um the um I suppose we we have
over provided um in terms of bungal um
affordable housing Bungalow provision um
within the scheme um it's quite unusual
uh for a scheme to
include uh Bungalows um we we've
responded to the requirements from the
Strategic housing officer um in in in
respect of uh providing precisely the
mix um that will meet uh loc local uh
needs within within the
scheme thank you thank you thank you
could I just ask myself um could a could
a bungalow or Bungalows be included in
any of the 13 self-build custom buil
plots possibility yes they they could
chair I mean and indeed that's something
that we had considered um as part of the
development of the scheme they're not
excluded that's fine they they're not
excluded no correct than councelor a
you're next followed by councelor
Busby councelor s uh good morning um I'd
just like to ask having um traveled that
road from burel down to the Wildman and
left to um because I Tau for 20 years
that road is really quite um narrow how
soon are you going to actually have the
road is it prior to the building or what
could you explain
please the road
improvements yes if I could just pick up
on on two points there so in in response
to um the question about the timing of
the delivery um of the road um it
envisioned that that would be brought
forward as part of the development um so
so it would be phased to co inside uh
with the delivery of the the new homes
the community facilities um as part of
the scheme
um what we' discussed with the highway
Authority is um the phasing and timing
of that being controlled via planning
condition um so so that would be set out
as part of the the overall construction
uh management um of the
scheme um but it's envisaged that um the
spine Road would be um providing the
link between between bural Lane and the
rainway um would be brought forward as
part of uh the the overall scheme um
just in ter in terms of um burst Lane
and uh how Su suitable it is for for
vehicles to use it um we we picked up on
um on the need to uh improve the highway
safety uh position in respect to bur
Lane and as part of the scheme we're
proposing uh passing Bays um on person
that would be delivered as part part of
the scheme um and we felt that that
struck an appropriate uh balance between
um providing uh providing uh an
Improvement to the safety of vehicles
using burst or Lane but without um going
to the extent of widening the road uh
and po potentially make it a more
attractive route uh um clearly we're not
trying to encourage more people to use
burst or
they can I come back there chair um can
I just say you need to have um
permission from the land owners for
those passing schemes and surely knowing
that road it would be the first priority
to put that spine Road in because
otherwise you're going to have heavy
vehicles for the building supply so
really we do need that quite soon don't
we um if I could back on W for thank you
um so um construction access um it would
be en vised would come would come
forward from the rainway so so there
wouldn't be any any construction access
um coming coming from bural Lan um so so
the existing um I think the case
officers um slide showed the access um
to the existing Caravan storage area on
Lorraine way um so so that that is the
proposed location um of the um fine Road
where where it would um access line way
um that it was was the detail of the
construction as say would be specified
through a construction management plan
in due course um it's invisage that
construction access would be provided
from the rainway not from buray um which
is u count councelor a quite quite
rightly suggests um is not is not a
suitable access for construction
vehicles um in terms in terms of the
passing bays and and um our ability to
deliver those um those are those are
proposed um as part of land that is um
within within the applicant control um
so so it's part it's it's either land
that's um uh within the applicants
control or within the the highway
boundary okay thank you just following
on from that um question from Council SS
uh if we were remed to approve the
application how quickly would you be on
site to start
this yeah so um we've set out a um a
delivery um timetable uh within within
the delivery statement um that members
will have received uh as part of the
briefing note um for for the scheme um
and um we've allowed um a reasonable
leading time for submission approval of
Reserve matters on the scheme um and uh
discharge of conditions and mo
mobilization to site um and we've
suggested that um we would be on site um
in the mon monitoring year
2022 um
2023 right thank you um canel Busby you
were
next surely I have you got a a developer
house bu builder in mind or have you got
one signed up for
it um not not at this stage um we we we
talked to a number of house uh Builders
um uh as members will be aware we're
we're involved in a number of schemes um
both within uh the region but also in
bber um itself um and uh we've had
significant interest um in bringing the
scheme forward um it's location within
the A14 um it's is clearly a desirable
location um so so we we continue to talk
to home uh Builders um about the scheme
um and we we're we're we're very
confident that um we we would be able to
select a home builder partner here um to
bring to bring the scheme forward within
the time frame that I I out allowed okay
sorry pet couple more questions if we
were to approve this application
uh but with a condition that you should
build the community building rather than
just provide a plot of land would you be
acceptable with
that uh that that's certainly something
um that we'd considered as part of the
um development of the of the scheme um
where we where we've um arrived at um
following discussions with uh the
community Parish Council um and offices
is that um
the the the permission should remain as
a flexible uh permission um so that it
allows for um either a community use um
either a local shop or office space to
be brought forward on that land um and
the intention is that that would be
secured via the section 106 agreement um
so there would then be a period of time
uh that would be um uh set set aside
effect effectively to explore the uses
that could come forward on that that
side um I think what I would say in
respect of um the land that's been
identified uh for the uses um for the
community uses the local shops and the
office space um is that there there has
been support from the council's economic
development team um in respect of
providing some uh some Modern um small
scale office space um on that part of
the on that part of the scheme um and
that's certainly um something that could
be brought forward um if there wasn't a
Community use um or or or or or a local
shop uh requirement I think PR have
answered that point I'll just asked
which might help you councel Busby
whether Joe Hobs um whether you wanted
to comment on that point
one yes no thank you chair um yeah the
uh the space obviously has been intended
to be flexible and so um it's uh you we
want to make sure that the use that
comes forward is the one that's wanted
by the community um or needed um by that
the market will deliver and the section
106 agreement will ensure that that site
is safeguarded for a period of time um
to make to try and enable it to come
forward so we'll have a period of time
where we've got a sustained marketing
strategy for um either retail or an
office use um and protect it but
obviously we we can't protect imp
perpetuity um if there's no interest in
that site coming forwards but hopefully
um with the evidence from economic
development team you know there's a
there's um there is interest out there
but I do take Council Busby point about
uh ensuring a building is actually built
on the site um that is the ideal um
situation it's just we have uh a
difficulty with the um knowing exactly
what that would be because we have the
flexibility of different uses um and so
because obviously different uh different
buildings have different specifications
and requirements so the scheme obviously
it's it's a it's a potential put
forwards but I have been careful in the
committee report to note obviously it's
it's not a significant benefit as there
is no um certainty over its delivery at
present um and um I'd be i' want to kind
of guide members to be careful obviously
placing too much weight on that as a
benefit for that very reason and and the
scheme doesn't hinge on the delivery of
those particular uses um in terms of it
being beneficial there are other
community benefits which we secure the
uh Community Woodland the allotments and
such like um that uh we definitely will
have certainty of delivery on um so um
yeah we we we have we have investigated
and I say the section 106 will um
control the situ ation to a degree thank
you counc can we move on no
um the point was uh look I know it could
be a generic building which they they
put the question to the applicant
remember yeah it's uh a commitment to
funding the building a piece of land is
just a piece of land it's it's no
Community benefit really they've got
plenty of land it's the cost of putting
the building up that they're what is
your question to the applicant sorry if
the if the applicant as part of this uh
doesn't build it would they be prepared
to put a sum aside to enable it to be
built in the future that's a fair
comment um um Mr snowland can you answer
that help yes of course chair um yeah I
mean I think I think um uh given unless
unless we have an identified use
um for the building um I think I don't
think we could commit to a sum of money
being put aside to bring It Forward that
that that's something we could we could
explore um in due course um I think it's
important to note that um the scheme
will deliver the village car park um
which sits to the south of the uh the
land that's been um reserved for the
community um local shop and employment
uh office space use um so so as part of
that Village car park being provided um
there will be um a private driveway uh
utilities infrastructure that will be
provided to effectively create a service
site
um thank you I think you've answered
that councel Buzby your next question
yeah um the self-build site plots they
look quite
large uh they certainly look larger than
the average plot size for the
development
um what would you expect to be built on
there they look at least four
bedroom sized
plots yeah so the um the self-build
plots um are are typically um quart
quarter an acre uh plots um they've been
designed partly um to allow uh for
um a house of between a three or four
bedroom house to be delivered um on the
on those plots um our experiences that
generally people who want to build um
their own home so people who are looking
to uh to bring self bu plot forward um
generally looking for um a detached uh
or looking to build a detached home um
and in some ways the um the the
positioning of The self- Bu plots has
been dictated by uh the design um so so
the the plots along bural Lane um with
sort to replicate the uh character um of
the lane so uh with a new Woodland belt
that be provided to the north of burel
Lane to replicate the southern side of
of the lane um with a private driveway U
which would then access the plots um to
the
north okay I mean it's I think it's it's
very next question well by leaving these
13 houses out of the market mix it it
does affect the percentage it's easy to
say that you've got a high proportion of
two and three bedroom houses because
you've excluded 13 which are probably
going to be four or five if you include
those in it drops the percentage down so
it's you know it's a marketing PLO isn't
it um
question how Dreadful of you to do it
don't you
think I that's not a question you don't
need to answer that can was a
thing do you have another question for
my voice I'm going to move on uh just
the the new you mentioned new employment
opportunities I just want apart from
building the houses which let's face it
we don't we don't have a problem with
putting houses up um what were the
employment opportunities that you talked
about so the um the land's been um
identified uh as uh office space um so
so we're we're envisaging uh small scale
um office space that would be provided
so creating um modern office space uh
that would meet the needs of people um
living or working in the village thank
you okay thank you thank you councelor
Busby uh we now have councelor
McLaren thank you uh good morning Mr
snan um the reason I asked the parish
council a question was how often you had
consulted with them and my concern is
that when you apply for outline
permission
you have a lot a big and of credit to
your company a good relationship or you
hope you've got a good relationship with
the parishes or The Villages that you um
are working with however because you
work with partner
Builders um when they come to apply for
detailed planning permission as we've
heard in the past that has not always
conformed with what you applied for
initially um How do you you feel about
this because I think some Villages and
some parishes are feeling let down by
the original uh
outline sorry the original outline
permission which appeared to respond to
their needs and
requests it sold on to a third party
you're right can you help that Mr sowan
yeah thank you um for the question um uh
I mean I think what um having having
listen to the the uh planning committee
meeting um where where the scheme in uh
question uh was um heard um I'm I'm
aware of the issu surrounding that
scheme um and I think um I I I I would
say that that's that's actually an
isolated in incident um all of the other
schemes that we've been involved with um
including those within the suffk uh area
have have delivered um uh broadly in
accordance with the mix that we have we
have uh set out at the outline stage um
I think it's unfortunate that in that
instance um that there there wasn't a a
condition um included on the planning
permission um and that's certainly um
what is envisaged here that there would
be be a planning condition um to ensure
that uh the mix that comes for at
Reserve matters stage um including the
prision of the Bungalow um including the
provision of the of the smaller Market
homes um would actually be delivered
uh substantially in accordance with uh
what's been set out now at this outline
stage and as I say that's something that
has uh pigeon are are completely
comfortable with um we've done that on
on other schemes um so so yeah I I I
hope that that will assure me Members um
that's an exception rather than a rule
thank you thank you yes I think this
particular planning committee has
learned lessons from that particular
situation that happened earlier
uh in the year um now I've got one left
and that's um uh cancel Barrett because
we still have the debate to come yes
thank you yes um I it's a similarish
area but uh in in terms of um questions
to yeah I'm getting there I'm sure you
are um the AR's impression is very
influential to me um because I thought
it was was good um showing what the
street scene might look like with the
the Tre trees and then showing maturity
as it might develop but I I want to know
how how realistic that might be um is
there a a a plan for the type of trees
and the maturity that that would be uh
provided so that we can have some uh you
know we understand that villagers are
very concerned about the loss of
landscape and things and that would
mitigate that somewhat if there's any
assurance that you can give on that good
question Mr s yeah of course um uh no
thank you um the uh the visualizations
that we've provided with the scheme um
was there illustrative in terms of the
building appearance uh the the um the
appearance of the buildings themselves
um will be uh determined through Reserve
Mass application in due course um the
landscape that's been shown um on those
visualizations is based upon the
landscape master plan uh for the
company's the outline planning
application um and um we we've uh we we
we' discussed the provision of
conditions uh that will be attached to
the outline planning permission that
will um ensure that the Landscaping is
provided um in accordance with what is
shown um on on the landscape master plan
um the uh the visualizations um in order
to to give a give a fair reflection of
how of how the planting will look um
show um the the planting when it's um
newly uh PL planted but also when it
becomes fully established as well um so
um it it envisages the P passage of time
um but in in terms of um yes Pro
providing the Landscaping um as we've
shown on the landscape master plan as
we've shown on those uh Vis
visualizations uh the details of that
would be would be secured via planning
condition thank
you uh councelor Barrett is that
it yes thank you yeah thank you there's
no other hands up members so um I'm
going to take it that we've asked all
the questions we wish to ask of the
agent so we'll move
on uh we now get to the point where we
ask the county counselor member
councelor Christoper Hudson uh you sir
have three minutes in which to address
the committee and your favor welcome
here this morning no afternoon it's now
12:00 good afternoon Mr chairman and
thank you for the invitation and good
good afternoon members and thank you for
the officer report and presentations can
you keep nearer to your mic or whatever
yes hear you nicely can you hear me now
yeah can you hear me now that's good uh
my concerns Mr chairman are based on two
main grounds if I may this this
afternoon one it's the health and
wellbeing agenda which I think is very
very important to all of us particularly
the residents of
spron secondly the highways which is as
you know Mr chairman is one of the
competences of the uh of the division
and of the
county really I think that this Parish
spron has been absolutely overwhelmed in
recent years may I say with hundreds
heading for the thousands of development
I believe that the development on a
highways front and particularly on a
health and uh health and well-being
front is totally
unsustainable I know that we've looked
at the amount of traffic going down the
the High Street in sporton tragically
we've had a fatality down there and any
number of accidents uh it's really a
very very dangerous bottleneck bural
Lane I know I hear of mitigation that
what what is planned but with this
particular speculative develop here I
I'm I'm a doubting Thomas Mr chairman
because I I I neither believe it to be
sustainable nor in the interests of the
parish I say that because of the fact
that one only has to go up and down the
road to Hadley there and you'll know
that better than anybody it really is a
no-go area they missed out on the boat
20 years ago with the bypass so the
traffic
situation it will really change the
relevant nature of the locality we will
move from having a medieval village a
hinterland
Village into what is becoming an urban
sprawl with toy towns attached to it and
I don't think that's sustainable Mr
chairman we do need to be concerned
particularly in the pandemic which
brings it to a head that people people
do need to get out into the Greener they
do need Fields not only to walk on they
need those fields to provide food as
well and the allotments are close by we
need more land we need more green spaces
for people to grow food and to enjoy
themselves and really I would invite
your committee this this afternoon Mr
chairman to really bear in mind that
from a highways point of view but more
particularly from a health and
well-being point of view this really is
a development too far amongst all the
other hundreds that we've had and I see
say I go so far as to say this will Mark
the death not now of spaen as we have
known it and it is our duty to Heritage
to ensure that we keep it safe thank you
Mr chairman thank you very much
councelor Hudson uh members have you any
questions uh for the county counselor uh
yes I've got councelor Hinton followed
by councelor
Osborne thank you Mr chairman counc joh
cancel Hudson um Can can you stay in the
meeting um put your mic on and your
camera on and um then councelor Hinton
lovely councelor Hinton your question to
councelor Hudson Yeah question for you
councelor Hudson as the County Council
are the highways Authority and they have
put in effectively um no comment other
than for standard 106 agreements and
also they've talking about gateways on
bural Lane which presumably are part of
the County council's Highway policy in
terms of slowing down traffic through
villages
how do you equate that with the eclectic
attitude they have to speed entering
villages in other parts of the district
and is there any way of us getting any
sort of logical comment from highways
concerning the problems along there
because I can remember when the rainway
was the bypass effectively for IP switch
before the A14 was built and then the
traffic seemed to seemed to flow
reasonably well now if there's a problem
on the a 14 everything just grinds to a
halt um there is no way that uh the
county council's current attitude
towards highways can be sustained and
you're effectively endorsing this uh and
saying that yes it cannot be cons um
sustained but at the same time are not
actually questioning the right people
namely your colleagues within the County
Council yes um one one can question as
long as one wants but because some
because one can do something doesn't
necessarily mean that one should do
something I'm referring we have a
nightmare background here which is the
A14 a12 complex and cck Doc Mill now
whilst this is not absolutely material
to this application in C2 it is
applicable to the overriding amount of
traffic that is whizzing up and down the
a12 and across the
A14 I don't necessarily feel sorry for
colleagues in the highways but I think
when one looks at what has been allowed
with developments in the past and we're
looking at what the highways have
allowed they are unsustainable it's
they've allowed far too much traffic to
flow through totally unsuitable streets
really Mr chairman some of those
thorough fares are no more than cattle
tracks Catt they are just byways and the
amount of work that's going on to do
this it's unsustainable and I I'm as I
say I'm a doubting Thomas and I will
even question my officers at highways
that perhaps they're not as close to the
spot and like any human being they can
make mistakes and this is a big one
thank you cancor
Hinton no he's gone right celor Osborne
sorry Mr chairman I'll take my hand down
right celor Osborne thank you Mr
chairman yes um councelor Hinton has is
has broached on on the area that was
going to
ask can I continue yeah has broached on
the uh stuff that I was going to ask
councelor Hudson about the one thing I'm
astonished by is you you talk about the
well-being and you talk about Green
Space and there and there we have suffer
County High County County highways and
highways England having no objections to
this all I seem to see from this uh
application on on highways grounds is
that you've moved one lot of uh
congestion to another and bural Lane
will become a a rat run and that will
then pick up on that a133 oh 113 sorry
um also um the the situation with cycle
route and and footpath does does that
mean that your foot path and cycle route
are going to continue down and and onto
113 how are you going to pick up a cycle
route down there I wouldn't like to
cycle down here for one moment but uh
you know I would have expected um a sa
County counselor uh dealing with an area
that he is involved with to have asked
the questions why have they cons have
they made any considerations about the
congestion that you're always going to
get down there thank you thank you
councelor Osborne you are pushing at an
open door I have made such
representations I will continue to make
such representations but I'm not an
officer of the county and of course they
have acted in very good faith and
they've acted very professionally all I
say as the elected member of the
constituents in this division is we do
not want this development it is
unsustainable from a highway point of
view I differ from the officers and I'll
continue to differ and I agree with you
councelor Osborne it's a nonsense and
I'm very frightened for cycl s and of
course this isn't the only site where
this is a problem but I do applaud the
green or quiet Lanes policy that's
coming in that is a very good Factor but
as regards the Parish of spron far too
much development too quickly with not
enough Highway provision and not enough
health and well-being provision thank
you Mr chairman thank you I think it's
fair to point out to both councelor
Osborne and and to support councelor
Hudson uh that the um High ways
Department are the experts that we have
to consult as planners as a planning
Authority and they come back after
they've made their investigations or
views or uh
deliberations and make an opinion which
they feel they can uphold um so it's
very difficult for uh County counselors
or or anybody to challenge these they
are the experts and whilst I don't like
it we do have to live with that um so
anyway we now have can um cancel Barrett
followed by councelor Parker councelor
Barrett your question to councelor hudon
thank you uh yes uh good morning uh good
afternoon councel husen um you will be
aware of the uh improvements that are
proposed at the roundabout um near Wy
Grange um that haven't yet been
delivered have they um I think it's been
called delayed by covid I think it was
due to to start work earlier but that
will no doubt
improve the flow of traffic into ITP
switch from Hadley Direction and it may
well have a a beneficial effect on the
village of spron because the you know if
you're choosing which way to go into
whip switch you might choose the the
upgraded um route instead of cutting
through do do you do you think that will
benefit and and um and and therefore you
know the the catastrophizing that we're
we're doing at the moment about what um
what traffic could be might might not be
as bad as as we
believe thank you and good afternoon
about it um you make a reasonable point
that we may well expect an improvement
or at least a mitigation if those things
go ahead there's no guarantee of that of
course the amount of people drifting
into the iwi area
and the coalesence of those parishes
into the greater Ipswich area the amount
of traffic is phenomenal and the
attendant pollution now one could also
say down the track we could well get
more and more electric cars and less
pollution and it will be easier for
traffic to go if you were to ask me this
morning on this particular application I
would say the effect of this development
will be very detrimental and it could be
years and years down the track who knows
with this terrible covid and The
Economic Consequences of it we may be
lucky to even buy a push guard in the
future because everybody as you know is
running out of resources what we used to
call money in the old so I think yes I'm
optimistic that we may get improvements
but my word I wouldn't like to hold my
breath thank you uh I think councelor
Barrett in answer to part of your
question regarding the wolsley gra uh
Road improvements uh they were as I
think you're aware meant to started in
early April and then they got uh stopped
because of the Culver um but since then
I have asked our officers to pursue with
the applicants as to why they can't get
it underway while there's less traffic
on the road and less people to be
inconen and I'm afraid the replies I've
got I think have just been excuses uh
they say on safety grounds um but uh
they are do to happen at some point in
time yeah all I tell I'm sure yeah thank
you councelor Parker your question to
councelor Hudson thank you chair and
it's a very very quick question um good
afternoon councelor Hudson I think in
your response to councel Osborne you
summed it up a treat Mr Hudson when you
said that you simply don't want this
development do you accept that this
planning committee cannot determine an
application based on the fact that it
doesn't want this
development
uh the the discretion of your committee
should never be feted it will it will
only decide things on planning matters
but at the end of the day it's not that
I don't want it for any unspecific
reason I don't want it for uh highways
reasons and health and well-being
reasons it is both unsustainable it's
unrealistic and I do not want a a toy
toown add-on that's an ungo situation
unviable as regards the road structure
in what is a rural setting so only on
planning grounds I have no vote in this
as you know Mr chairman but I believe it
to be unsustainable for the reasons I've
given it's not a predilection against
planning applications I try to approach
logic when I decide thank
you thank you councelor Parker uh
councelor Busby you're the last hand of
got up to celor Hudson yes Pro it
probably shouldn't be to Chris really
because I don't think you can answer it
but and probably to Joe but does the
report up your mind this is a question
to kelor Hudson you're more than capable
of putting it to him if you wish if he
can't answer it then I'll say if
Joe okay um are the highways team
capable of joined up thinking bearing in
mind that in this report they seem to
suggest that the there will be
improvements to the Beagle
roundabout but my understanding is that
in Wy Grange Development coming from
forward they're going to turn it into a
traffic
lights good afternoon Dave um of course
of course they're capable of joined up
thinking but sometimes they don't
achieve it
thank thank you very much for that one
councelor Hudson and councelor Busby uh
there's no other hands up so um with
that then I'm going to move on thank you
counselor Hudson County counselor for
the area um
right we now move to the ward member and
it's councelor sack Norman uh you have
five minutes in which to address the
committee thank you thank you afternoon
even yes good morning everybody and
thank you very much for the opportunity
to speak um before I begin to discuss
the reasons um why because I've I've
agreed with um all the speakers so far
um Chris thank you very much you've made
some great points there um there are
many policy reasons why this should be
refused but I just wanted to take the
opportunity to mention the community
Discord around this application uh the
community ever since hearing about this
application has been very unsettled and
if it was to be approved it would set
quite a dangerous president and could
ruin what many people actually love
about the village and why they moved
here in the first place there are over
300 objections on this application and
they aren't only from parishioners in
our area uh but also from further a
field in burel elmet Ranford hinam
chattam and cop do and washbrook and
this is because of the detrimental
cumulative impact that this application
would cause to the area as has been
touched on already uh a huge issue with
this application is the traffic issue I
personally live on Sport and High Street
so I know the traffic issue all too well
um going to work and coming home every
morning is an absolute nightmare with
all the traffic congested uh up to the
Beagle roundabout in both directions the
proposed spine Road won't help to ease
this congestion at all it would simply
move it to another Junction um and most
people who use the wild man Junction are
either going straight ahead to go
towards it switch or are turning right
the majority of people that are using
that when they're coming to and from
work aren't going to be turning left to
go to Branford or cayen which is the
only circumstance where the spine Road
would actually improve the situation uh
most and most of Sportland traffic
problems have their roots in the fact
that the comp talk interchange doesn't
work anyway so anything that's actually
done in the village to try and improve
congestion won't actually achieve
anything because our roots are very deep
rooted in the cop dog interchange of why
the traffic in sporton is so bad um
sporton is currently in the process of
carrying out a neighborhood plan as was
touched on earlier um this plan is being
carried out by members of our community
and is in the gather evidence phase uh
this is expected to come to parition at
the end of 20121 and has already
performed a site allocation um from the
household survey there is 31% of our
local Community State um there are many
different factors that oppose the we uh
development behind the wild man such as
the positive features of spren being
open and green fields local wildlife and
habitats as well as the negative
features being highlighted as the volume
and speeds of traffic and pedestrian
safety so by by approving development
behind the wild man it would simply
remove What the residents love about the
community and enhance everything that we
hate the community have highlighted that
in their response that 50 to 100 homes
are needed in the Parish of spon in the
next 20 years we've already had 30 homes
built in Church Lane and further to that
another 475 approved on the Wy Grange
one so that's at least 55 and Wy Grange
2 is also expected to come forward for
another a thousand or more which goes
well above and beyond our Pro proven
local need another section of the
household survey mentioned the natural
environment and over 80% of respondents
said that our housing needs should not
take priority over the local environment
99% of respondents said that our peace
and Rural quiet is important and over
94% of respondents said that our history
and built Heritage is important if the
development of these 105 houses were to
go ahead it would simply destroy our
natural
environment sporton does not have as a
village doctors dentist or other public
services and any new residents on a
development of this size wouldn't
wouldn't have access to these services
without having to drive a car therefore
increasing pollution traffic and ruining
the standard of living for those that
are living here in the Liz Lake uh
Associates visual impact assessment that
was submitted with the application it
states that the sensitivity of this area
lies in its produced Valley slopes which
provide setting to the Village Edge it
has a simple and open character which
allows long views out to the Northwest
contained and fringed by Woodlands on
the skyline the only Built form in this
area is the wild man Pub which sits on
the bottom of the valley on a staggered
Crossroads backed by allotments to the
Northwest and the valley side is open
and highly sensitive to development any
development on this special landscape
area which you would have seen from the
views and the videos that you've seen
would ruin our views and also impact the
visual the visual impact of the wild man
Pub which is a gray two listed building
this application has no public benefit
to the Village other than clear policy
requirements with any consideration to
the community or the surrounding area in
order to comply with the settlement
patent policy which is CS2 this
development would have to be specially
designed to fit into the area however
this is being ignored due to the visual
impact from the Wildman listed building
creeping coalescence with neighboring
Villages such as Branford and clayon
also merging us with IP switch and it
does not comply with less than
substantial harm also as from the
attachment yesterday from Robert Hobbs
we also have a 5year land Supply without
this application in terms of policy CS2
cs15 for sustainable development and
cs11 are being contradicted our
strategic policy sp8 is being
contradicted in terms of infrastructure
provision and the local policies lp16
for Environmental Protection
particularly where it talks about
agricultural land in paragraph 1 a and
2A and also lp30 for safe sustainable
and active transport and also lp1 for
hamlets and clusters of development in
the countryside under paragraph 3 and
lp8 for landscape that whole policy is
in contradiction if this development to
go ahead thank you very much thank you
very much for that celor Norman uh
members have you any questions to
councelor Norman yes councelor
Busby yeah ISAC um just a thought in
terms of this the timing of this
application we know that the Hopkins
home one is up for
appeal if it gets the go-ahead in
the how much would that change the
villagers views of this particular
development because the view from a lot
of the listed buildings would change
significantly no you're quite right well
if it was going to be both of them going
ahead you've obviously got to think of
the cumulative impact from both of those
anyway and in terms of the views if
Hopkins homes was approved then
obviously you've got to think of the
views from the All Saints Church the
listed buildings in that area but
regardless of that if that was approved
the Wildman Public House is the one that
would be most affected by this
development and that with Hopkins homes
it wouldn't particularly change the
setting so much of the wild man but from
this development being directly behind
it it would hugely disrupt the setting
of that thank you thank you any other
questions there's no hands
up thank you councelor Norman then we'll
move on thank you um we have the second
W member councelor harder you also have
five minutes in which to address the
committee sorry chair councelor harder
isn't here um he declined the meeting
that was in anticipation if he was here
on your script apologies thank you okay
so we haven't got councelor
harder just check have we got anything
in writing from councelor harder instead
of him being here in person not to my
knowledge
cancel received either Mr pre fair
enough thank you okay chair sorry can I
just come in it's Joe um Council harder
did forward a comments um some comments
to me saying he um supported the parish
council and um Council Norman's comments
I I did refer to that presentation so
I've given a verbal update of his
comments that he submitted on the
application just for Just for
information thank you very much we note
that thank you right members then I'll
now open It Up For Debate so um oh Kor
Parker well done you can start
thank you chair um right if I could um
could I just ask a question of Joe or a
couple of questions please of Joe just
for clarification um purposes um sorry
chair I've got um uh I think Mark
Russell has just interjected do you want
to take that uh thank you if that's okay
with you I will take it uh Mark um yes
I'm I'm sorry chair I had my hand up I
didn't want to interject and interrupt
but I just thought before the debate
started yeah can you hear okay yes yes
okay on yeah I just want to clear up one
or two points
um just just to reemphasize as you've
already done chair because we went back
to it again the highway Authority didn't
object I know but we went back to that
after You' made your point I just want
to clarify no um harm was identified
substantial harm which would result in
in a refusal so we heard what the County
Council has said but we we can't really
go there with the highway reasons for
refusal so I'm sure we all knew that
anyway um Council Norman mentioned
neighborhood plan which had been
mentioned earlier that the weight it
carries is is very limited at the moment
it's very early in its process so we
can't really afford that any weight um
and the other two points relate to the
lessons we learned with um
Klondike um Joe Joe's already given some
some long answers on this but I think
having discussed this with her we
probably need to revisit the condition
relating to the two and three bers and
also the issue of Bungalows so if I may
C can Joe just have the the mic again
and explain how we're going to deal with
that and then that will inform the
debate and therefore the resolution
thank you thank you uh and before I lose
you Mark can you um uh I can't see your
hand for whatever reason um so if you do
at the game you'll have to interrupt me
okay chat box yeah that's fine chat box
yeah then that way I'll know thank you
Joe thank you chair um yes as alluded to
earlier the housing mix the number of
bedroom sizes we've got a condition but
we can can um add some words to say the
housing mix shall predominantly be two
and three bedroom but we do need to um
obviously be flexible so I think we need
to have uh wording in the condition to
say unless in the reasons justification
is given otherwise um because if there's
new housing um evidence in arar
obviously we want to reflect that um but
uh yeah we certainly can add that
wording to the housing Ms conditions so
we'll we'll um if my members are minded
to um go with a recommendation then we
can add that in um with regarding uh
bungalows obviously um we've got um up
to 10 Bungalows indicative at present if
the number of dwellings reduces on site
we can't get 105 in um it may be that
one of the affordable Bungalows doesn't
come forward so again I think we we will
have we will look to secure up to 10
Bungalows and we be very clear that
obviously this is a key um part if
members are minded to a key part of the
members resolution um and again if it's
not possible to provide up to 10 B
Bungalows then a reason justification
must be given so we're doing all we can
do we can't at this stage um definitely
secure the 10 Bungalows I think that's
the point I want to get across to
members but we can do everything we can
to raise it to Future developer of the
site that this is a matter of importance
for the committee and that they need to
provide a good reason justification if
that changes at the reserve matter stage
now with the Bungalow um um issue I I
wouldn't it would be good if we could
have potentially the opportunity to be
secure it by conditional section 106 we
just need to get some further have some
further discussions or legal advice on
that matter but we would look to secure
it through either one of those routes
and so that's something else perhaps
we'd want to note um with the resolution
um if uh if members are minded to go
with it so hopefully hopefully that's
sufficient thank thank you yes that's
certainly a lot stronger than what um
and picks up all our points I think um
right councelor Parker back to you super
job thank you chair um right yes Joe so
uh I was I was going to say um councelor
Davis in her presentation uh to
committee mentioned two points and I
just wanted to finally have your
comments on the first one was uh the
2015 landscape report uh and councelor
Davis mentioned that um as a result of
that report babber considered that this
site uh wouldn't uh wouldn't be an
appropriate site to bring development
forward on so if I could have any
comments on that and then secondly she
mentioned about creeping coalescence a
number of speakers have have talked
about that but creeping coalesence
that is not in accordance with the nppf
so um she has a fair point there doesn't
she Joe sorry Joe you're muted sorry
unmuted thank you councelor yes the 2015
um study that was referred to uh is a
piece of evidence um that has looked at
the site um and identified that it does
have sensitivities um which this
planning application has also identified
Heritage um landscape sensitivities um
but the the planning application uh
obviously looks at uh wider matters than
just the evidence that the purposes that
that report was written for um we need
to look at all the material
considerations the um requirement to
consider Heritage and Landscape harm but
then throw it into the planning balance
and consider um whether a development
would be acceptable under our
development plan and the mppf so it is a
piece of evidence and I is reflected in
the findings of this application uh the
consult comments that we've received and
hopefully in the committee report that
there are harms associated with this
site but that report in itself doesn't
mean in planning terms that we can just
say no to this development we have to
consider the development plan and mpbf
material
considerations um with regard to
settlement coalescence that's something
certainly something that we've
considered with the landscape impact um
through the landscape visual impact
assessment so we looked at thought
considered coalesence with um Branford
um but also burst ORS obviously it kind
of sits um um nearer two other
development areas we consider that there
is still sufficient um uh Visual and
physical separation with proposed
development particularly with the
revised scheme that has come back down
the valley side so it's not so prominent
um within the landscape there's still
sufficient uh separation so there
wouldn't be that physical um coalesence
with either of those two communities um
and so we don't consider that is a a
strong reason that could be used to
refuse the application we consider it is
acceptable in those landscape terms
thank you thank you councelor Parker um
any any other member want to make
comment no one uh councelor
Busby yeah loads of comments to make
actually chair but uh the first one
really is it's the timing of this
application that concerns me really
when you think that we with the jlp is
based over what a 20 year 25 year plan
MH and we've got to De deliver these
this level of housing over that period
it doesn't all have to be delivered in
year one I mean we have't even started
the bloing thing yet and we've already
achieved huge percentage of that housing
need in spron they've already allocated
what 12200 houses if not more of it how
many houses do you need now in spron and
I think the answer is none so if it's
come forward in say 10 years time I
think it would be more justifiable
equally I'm suspicious that it's been
brought forward now before the
jlp has been totally approved because
the number that they've applied for is
40%
higher than what's in the
JP
I don't know why I mean I'm a suspicious
type of person I just think it's
obviously a greater benefit to have 105
houses on the site rather than 75 and
then there's the appeal it it again it
just seems strange for us to make a
decision based on on this one now when
there's an appeal on the side the other
side of the road which I think will will
have I know what Zach says but I think
will have a material impact on the way
that this committee should decide on
this one
if the
appeal is upheld so that they get
approval that could make a big
difference to the way we think but if
the appeal is thrown out on Heritage
grounds again I think that will make a
difference on how we would approach this
one so at this point I'm I'm almost
money to uh propose a deferral but I'll
let the debate continue before I make
that thank you well well I just have to
remind we have to deal with what's in
front of us and we have to deal with on
the policies that we have that are up to
date and with us at this present time um
but councelor Parker you wanted to come
back followed by councelor
Barrett um yeah thank you chair because
um I I I kind of sense that actually of
of all debates this this one was
probably going to go in in a certain
direction that Council Busby has just
just pointed to actually um and I think
we would probably need to take some
advice again from our officers because a
simple SE of the mppf shows that
paragraph 50 um deals with prematurity
in in decision making and refusal of
planning permission on grounds of
prematurity will seldom be justified
where a draft plan has yet to be
submitted so I think it's a bit uh it's
unfortunate uh and I understand where
councelor Busby is coming from but on
what on What planning grounds around the
jlp the forthcoming jlp could we
possibly uh choose to refuse this
application Mark and Ian can can you
between you um pick up these points that
councelor Busby and councelor Parker
have just
highlighted um I'm sure Mark Mark should
go first I'll help if need be but thank
you
Mark right I'm here so the question is
can we defer this or even refuse it
because it's premature in relation to
the jlp is that the question that's been
asked y um well well well no we can't
because um it's we we can't do that
we've got to we've got to treat things
as per the um the current set of
policies as I think you've just said um
Joe Hobs can tell you some more about
this if that's okay yeah I just just I
agree strongly with Mark not much else I
can
say
Joe yeah thank you chair yes um
obviously um The Joint local plan is at
an early stage um in development at
present which is why I didn't uh
particularly labor on it in the
presentation and it's clear in the
committee report we can't place
significant weight on that at present um
but I I I take Council of bby's point
that we should wait to see where this
goes and the appeal site goes um but
unfortunately um particularly joint
local plan we can't um seek to defer
because our plan isn't um quite at that
right stage yet we are under um the
requirement from government to progress
applications in a timely manner and
determine them under the current
development plan as as Mark has said so
unfortunately um we we we are under the
owners from central government to
progress planning applications as
quickly as possible particularly in the
last few months to try and stimulate um
economic uh growth where possible um but
we have to look at are there any reasons
here before us today that this planning
application should be refused that is
the question that I would advise members
to consider um not that we have a
pending appeal um or a joint local plan
emerging I think they they are um
Dangerous Grounds to be refusing
planning application on potentially um
deferring applications on as well we uh
we under the requirement to progress
applications um as we can now hope it
answers the question councelor
Parker sorry can I come back in there
chair I've got
you sorry he posed the question uh to
the officers so that's why I'd come back
to him first can par I would just I
would just very quickly say chair that
that that um sort of confirms my my line
of thinking uh on that thank you thank
you councelor bosby well thank you uh
Mark you said that we can't right use
the JP policies because it's not been
approved yet therefore the current
policies are the ones that we have to
judge it by which is
fine so CS2 therefore is important
because this is a site outside the
village boundary and therefore this will
only be permitted in ex exceptional
circumstances subject to a proven
justifiable or Justified need and I
think that's a very important
sentence right because I'm not convinced
that they've proved exceptional
circumstances or that there's a proven
Justified need and I need to be commit
convinced of that before I could vote
for it that's a sage Point based on I
said so I yeah I accept why you say that
obviously we're talking about saved
policies um and CS2 is just about
holding up but on its own has been
proven appeal after appeal not to be a
determinative policy in its own right so
you then have to look at all the other
policies as well so CS2 on its own
cannot be a reason for refusal or
deferral here um and may whilst I've got
the microphone chair just in terms of
the issue of timing the application um
it was submitted in February 2019 so
it's it's it's been in a long time it
wasn't submitted to try and play the the
jlp it just happens to be here now with
us today
thank you I've got councelor Barrett
followed by councelor Hinton councelor
Barrett thank you chair um just looking
at the arguments against approval um
that we've heard
highways this completely ignores the
improvements that are going to happen at
the woy gra um sort of uh effect um the
I think it's the Beagle roundabout um
and and along along that stretch um
and yes on the accumulative argument um
Wy Grange is uh has planning permission
for a large number and and perhaps more
but it just happens to be in in spren
it's rather different to many other
Villages where you would see the the
development coming
alongside it's it's actually uh butting
up against Pinewood um if the boundary
was drawn any differently you can
imagine it it not being in in sporten I
don't think that we could really take
that as a cumulative effect on the
village of spron it it it has it will
have a a huge effect on the the IP
switch Fringe but I don't believe it
will on
spon
um I I don't see the the grounds for
refusal really
um the the sustainability argument is is
I think that that's pretty established
that there are jobs locally there are
amenities nearby there are good
transport links with the A14 you know we
haven't heard a lot about those because
because they are they are pretty
established they they are um on the
doorstep
um and I I I'm just I you know I've
listened to the officer's argument about
um
CS2 um and so I'm I'm you know I'm
having to accept that basically as a as
a valid argument um I don't really see
the grounds for
refusal I'll leave it there for the
moment thank you councelor
Hinton thank you Mr chairman well on
what councelor Barrett's just been
saying well one of the grounds besides
uh CS2 of course is cs1 where the
officers have already admitted that they
haven't put in a housing needs
requirement um that meets the criteria
of cs11 and I'm sure if that is expanded
to actually
include woy gra as part of spron which
it is whichever way you look at it um
then uh there is no need also if you add
into that the results of the the
recently well yesterday uh released AMR
which shows that we're sitting at the
moment or or rather developers are
sitting on
4,417 permissions that they haven't even
started on yet uh and here we are
talking about giving even more
permissions we also know that this
particular developer has a a a record if
you like to call it that of putting in
an application which sounds very good
and is very difficult to refuse as an
outline and include some fairly Bland
statements about Bungalow affordable
housing Etc but when you look at the
information that the proposers got got
in the report it talks about most of
those affordable houses being in blocks
of one-bedroom Flats well doesn't that
sound a bit familiar when youd like
think about Klondike where all over half
the affordable houses were in one
particular block of flats uh then you
add into that the environmental impact
of everybody getting onto the a12 and
going somewhere because the one thing
that we haven't got in ipsd is a surfit
of
employment that's one of the things we
haven't got we're going to see some new
jobs in the Amazon Depot at uh on the
sugar be Factory site but all of the
jobs in the main food warehousing uh
site were transferred from other
locations across the Eastern region
really so they weren't actually new jobs
at all they were just moved in from
somewhere else uh and if we add into
that the mppf talks about not joining up
communities uh I'm sure that uh
councelor bar would be receive a fairly
Frosty reception from people in spon if
they said that they ought to be because
they lived in Wy Grange they ought to be
part of pinewood um because many a
village around the outside of urban
areas has been swallowed up and
disappeared from site and they resent
it we should respect the fact that they
are um independent um communities and
look after them in that respect so we've
got highways where we don't get any
support from them all because I'm
sometimes wonder whether they actually
come out of their office and see what's
going on anywhere um they talked in my
Village about widening up the aspects
into the village to slow down the
traffic here they're talking about
putting a gated approach to the Village
to slow down the traffic they've got
their act get get their act together and
decide what what the policy actually is
and the mppf of course is uh is a valid
document whether we like it or not but
both copies of the mppf both the
original and the latest version talk
about maintaining the identity of
individual communities and not joining
them up together so I think we've got
sufficient reasons there to uh including
the landscape ones to actually uh refuse
this and also of course if you think
about the landscape one the indicative
plans of what a tree looks like in five
years time that's assuming it's growing
like a rocket because looking at the
size of those trees at the start and the
size they were supposed to be in 5 years
time they'd had to be on something
pretty marvelous in the ground to make
him grow that quick not even a conifer
would get that hype that
quickly thank you um Joe can you comment
um on the point to councelor um Hinton
the point
cs11 um because you did have some
concerns but is there enough concerns
there to wait and support a refusal I
think that's what it was
suggesting yes thank you chair yes
indeed my conclusion to my committee
report did note there tension with cs1
the the proposals broadly comply with
the policy in many aspects but there is
tension with regard to local housing
need doesn't fully demonstrate the U
required requirements of cs11 but um as
my uh conclusion notes the uh the
consideration of the application is
obviously wider we need to look at the
benefits of the scheme and also the
requirements of material considerations
the mppf to boost our land Supply and
when considering the benefits the
location all the benefits I've listed
before I won't go through them again um
that is considered to form a a a good
material consideration that supports
approval of the scheme and uh refusal of
the um application on the grounds of not
fully addressing housing need on cs1
Alone um I don't consider that would be
um upheld at appeal um so my advice is
that this scheme should be approved even
with that conflict with cs11 thank there
isn't the weight there in your opinion
Mr if I could come back on that Mr
chairman sorry sorry can I will let
councelor Hinton um just respond to that
um with all due respect to Joe she talks
about tension here um the the latest
planning consultation from central
government talks about discretion as
being part of the decision-making in
planning and surely this is where we
should use our discretion and say it
doesn't comply with cs11 go away and
sort it out properly because that's one
of the things that they can do with a
refusal is go away sort out the reasons
that we put forward for refusal and then
come back but if we approve we're
saddled with it we can't do anything
about it we're stuck um so um Joe Hobs
can you can you respond to
that um yes yeah I do take your point
councelor Hinton um that uh the
requirement to demonstrate cs1 but I I
can only say what my advice was that I
don't think that that's a strong reason
that will withstand appeal um with in
line with other current appeals that we
have had decisions on um I don't think
the council would win uh an appeal on
that matter with this application with
the other benefits that this scheme
delivers I think that's all I can advise
you unfortunately thank you sorry
councelor Parker it is you
now thank you chair and and actually the
conversation has moved on quite a bit
because um I I just wanted and thank you
Joe for for clarifying because it it um
it confirms one of the points that I was
going to make and and I think chair you
know I've got some real sympathy um and
empathy with with the points that
councelor Hinton has has brought up
there uh and and he mentions about us um
you know defending Villages Etc and and
and of course that is what we're here
for as elected representatives and and
and of course it I I I mention again
about the neighborhood planning um
process and and uh and within the
neighborhood planning process of course
lies the the the perfect tool for this
committee to uh to be able to defend um
communities if the word that we want to
use unfortunately here it is a point of
fact we've already mentioned that the
jlp uh has limited weight unfortunately
the neighborhood plan has even less
weight by virtue of of of where it is in
in the plan process at the moment and
and I'm I'm reminded of a a planner many
years ago who said it's always darkest
before the dawn and and and what he
meant by that is is that um
unfortunately until that neighborhood
plan is progressed to a certain stage um
it it's going to be really difficult for
us as as a planning committee to be able
to uh to refuse so so really my question
was going to be to councel Hinson in
response to him as much as I I uh from a
Sentimental point of view as much as I
support what he's saying he will know
and every member of this committee will
know only too well that we are bound uh
by planning laws that we have and and
the local plan that we we're dealing
with at the moment um so the question is
is are the are the items that councilor
Hinton is describing as as means of of
refusal um are they robust or or are
they tenuous and and Joe has then gone
on in my opinion to explain that
actually that they they would
unfortunately be uh of of a tenuous
nature and how will that stand up um at
appeal um so um rhetorical questions
there um chair and I know I can't see
anybody else has got their hands up so
I'm just hoping that was going to
invigorate some further debate well
there is one hand up that's canel AB
Busby
of course it
is you're more than welcome cancor
pby there isn't going to be one aspect
here that is going to determine whether
we should turn it down or not it's again
it's like all these things it's
subjective isn't it it's you've got to
weigh up the the balance of the benefits
and the harm and to me I try and do that
for each one and it's like a a seesaw
really on the on the benefit side what
are the benefits
well really it's only about having a 100
houses that's it there's nothing special
about these houses they're not
particularly environmentally friendly
that's just basically 100 houses do we
really need 100 houses not especially
not especially there so there's no
particularly fantastic benefit from it
but the
harm when you look at the individual
things that I think it does Mount up I
mean if we take
the listed buildings I remember an
application we had in chilon where the
chilon hall was 300 M from a particular
site the only thing you could see was
the top of the chimneys yet there was a
huge fuss about the harm to the children
Hall and here we are in spron with what
a dozen or more listed buildings all
within sight of this application and
we're ignoring the harm that's being
done to them well I don't I think that's
significant once you build on that site
that view to the Village has gone
forever now we again we had this issue
with in KY where a field which couldn't
be seen from six Cottages was deemed to
be
significantly important six cottages for
a view of a field that couldn't be seen
here we have a whole village that has a
view onto the the Rolling Hills and a
number of listed
buildings that should be significant far
more significant than the ones that
we've had in Chilton and in KY
so you can't negate that loss of view
sticking trees
up doesn't change the fact that the view
is gone okay it might be still green but
it's the wrong kind of view now it's
houses and trees and if you took the
view from the public footpath 9 if you
walk along public foot path 9 now as you
saw from the slides you've got a
fantastic Vista right across the valley
right into the other side of hip
switch that's going to go because all
you'll see are trees and
houses and that is significant and we
make the decision to build these houses
now and the that view and the landscape
has gone and I think they're significant
pieces of harm and they should I think
negate the minor benefits we get from
100 houses 100 houses remember of which
we don't get sill on a lot of them
because they're going to be self-
builds and we don't get sill on
self-build so there's no contribution to
the infrastructure from
those you
know I think we just need to be a bit
more careful when we do this Balancing
Act to add up all of the harmful effects
that it has
rather than just assume that 100 hous is
good and what the hell it's a field
anyway what's a field it's in my view
that is quite an important
view thank thank you the Chilton site
referred to was approved by the way
canor Busby um councelor Parker your
next followed by councelor
Hinton thank you chair and and at the
risk of um playing a game of pingpong I
will also just remind um um councelor
Busby that in the KY application
actually the officer recommendation for
that was refusal and councelor Busby
himself supported the application and
the loss of the Heritage imunity but
we're not here to discuss the the KY
application um on his point
with on with regards to his point around
the sill I think it's worth noting that
I think I'm right and so Joel confirmed
that 92 of those properties will be
liable for sill uh I would imagine um
and uh of course 15% of that seal
contribution will automatically come
back to um to to the parish uh in in
order to provide um some of the
infrastructure that it's uh that's being
talked
about um Joe can you just um answer that
point yeah yeah obviously um the private
Market dwellings will um deliver sill
but the affordable dwellings um wouldn't
be still liable neither would the um 13
self-build dwellings so um it wouldn't
be the uh 92 um excuse my um quick maths
it would be um um
55 of the market dwellings my
understanding but a large a proportion
will deliver s and there obviously a
number of other um uh contributions
secur to the section 106 agreement as
well and I think we we obviously need to
be minded that we have no objections
from the infrastructure providers and
they consider that with the contribution
secured that um it will be adequately
addressed through this application thank
you thank you um councelor
Hinton
thank you Mr chairman yeah Joe's just
answered my question I was just going to
clarify for councelor Parker and
councelor Busby that of course um
affordable housing doesn't carry any s
contribution either so when you've got a
a social housing cont uh element within
a development then there's no s from
that either so they're they're wonderful
people that in Social houses they they
don't actually have an impact on
anything um but that's beside the point
that's that's the rules and regulations
um but the other point that I was just
going to break was one of the positives
that was being put forward was moving
the village car park uh to a different
location is that supposed to try and
encourage people to move their cars from
outside their houses along the uh the
Main Street uh so that they don't get in
the way of everybody because
um anywhere else where car parking is
supplied away from the from the
properties concerned people don't use it
for the simple reason they like to look
at their car to make sure that it's not
being burgled in the middle of the night
and there's no point in having an alarm
on the car if you can't see whose alarm
it is that's gone off uh when it's being
vandalized around the around the back of
the houses in a different location so
parking in a a village car park I'd like
to wonder who's actually going to use it
are people going to commute to spron
park up and then get on their bicycles
or get on the bus although I think
there's only one bus service goes into
into whip switch so uh it's all a bit
dubious as to what the uh the benefits
from from a lot of these aspects that
are being put forward are uh I'm sure
that the the people of spon would have
some comments on
that um Joe did you want to answer on
that I would have thought parking
facilities are always an improvement but
uh anyway we'll wait and see Joe what's
your comment yeah yeah I just wanted to
um um make clear that um it's additional
car park the there's no moving of a
village car park it's just an additional
Village car park to the existing um and
um where it's located it's located
obviously close to the allotments um
existing residences have you know their
parking situation I I take the point
that it's unlikely someone's going to
want to park their car out the way
around the corner but there are
potentially visitors to the village and
visitors to the alotment who may want to
drive there and then obviously visitors
to um the um future um Community office
or uh shop use on the site although that
does have its own car park as well so it
is just providing another opportunity
for parking to take the pressure off the
uh parking area near the uh lower Street
Wildman Junction at present um and just
provide like I say opportunity for the
allotment holders and such like to Park
thank you canor
Barrett thank you chair um we've heard
an awful lot and I I wonder whether
there's anything else that that that
remains to be said so I'm going to uh
propose that we approve the
application uh in line with the officer
recommendation
um and I'd just like to say I think
there are benefits um that can't be just
ignored uh there's self-build which I've
never seen before in an application in
in the couple of years I've been doing
this so that is quite um quite a a nice
thing to to see happening um Community
wood uh the spine road that will take
some of that uh away from that Junction
which is apparent ly such a problem that
it obviously does need something to be
done about it um the affordable houses
the Bungalows that are affordable that's
that's good and let's not just sort of
Sid um you know ignore these things uh
Village car park who knows who's going
to use it but but it's good to have um
retaining allotments the additional
public right away so um I'll see see if
I can get a seconder yes I'll I'll see
if I can get second in a moment could I
just um add um would this also include
the additional comments uh that was made
by um the case officer for the um mix
and the other points that we brought out
during the discussion well yeah I mean
that it doesn't seem very ambitious
really to say at least 10 Bungalows um
because I think that's bit outa word
I'll see whether um okay Joe can you
help us out on
this uh yes it's just uh the wording I
suggested was just to reflect the fact
that this is outlin and the number of
dwellings that may come forwards May
reduce and so it may be that the housing
mix we go down to nine Bungalow um I we
just need to have a mind to be
reasonable considering it is an outline
stage and we haven't got a fully worked
up Reserve matters at the moment but I
think the point that um of having a
fully reason justification as to why
it's anything less than 10 gives us uh
as officers and yourselves as members
the chance to really interrogate why
because I think recent experience um was
it was unexpected perhaps the developer
wasn't expecting to have to provide
Bungalows where this will clearly
demonstrate it is an expectation of this
scheme to provide Bungalows and a good
justification needs to be given if not I
think that's what we will aim to achieve
through the section 106 or condition oh
so that's fair and you're happy with
that councelor Barrett well I think it
has has to be a significant um part of
the
development um because because you know
we know we know that there's a a need
for that just anecdotally uh we are we
are aware of that the applicants are
listening in so hopefully they'll be
taking note as well anyway um I know
must ask for a second her and I've seen
a hand go up uh I think Steven Plum
yours was up before then sue a I think
you came up uh are you second um are you
going to be a second would you like to
speak very glad I I totally agree with
all the points made by Melanie and and
also I think Joe has put in tremendous
amount of work so um well done and I
think we need to go with the way we've
been advised by our officers thank you
thank you uh councelor Plum you you were
next than can you hear me only just
thank you chair up hear me now I I've
sat and listened um to both sides of the
argument here and and I think it's
coming down between the difference
between heart and
head and I'm afraid that without um a
joint local plan or a neighborhood plan
to steer Us in any other direction we've
just got to I'm afraid go for approval
afraid thank thank you thank thank you H
pal any any other comments um before ah
um Mark Russell too plan off want yeah
thanks CH I just just want to confirm
before the vote I mean we've pretty much
covered it but but the extra bit to the
recommendation will be you're you're
delegating to offices to cover those
points we'll talk about whether it'll be
in a condition or the 106 or both but
we'll deal with that matter afterwards
so can we at have it that matter is
delegated to officers that relating to
the two or three bedroom and The
Bungalow
issue uh councelor Barrett I don't know
if you're happy about that yeah as long
as it's ambitious enough um to to um you
know and I think that is reasonable to
to to push um the developer to make sure
that the provision is in line with you
know the the committee's uh wishes which
have been clearly expressed today to see
um the the smaller units and the
bungalos So
currently sorry are you happy to accept
that as
well sorry cancor
as yes I totally agree thank you sorry
there's just still a little bit of lack
of clarity there Joe's explained why a
maximum of 10 would be the fair wording
um do I have the impression there's a
descent from that point or will we keep
it as
that I I would like to see more but do
you not think that that is possible to
express a bit more ambition I think
there's always this thing about
Bungalows I understand it but even if
you look at the jlp which okay is
emerging and hasn't got a lot of weight
the percentage we're looking for those I
think it's 3% isn't it Bungalows so that
that's the way going forward so why are
we wanting a lot more here you'd have to
probably justify why you wanted a bit
more in the way of Bungalows unless we
take away the idea you'd like more and
we'll try but we can't promise I mean
maximum 10 does sound like Fair wording
don't forget he didn't rule out there
was a possibility there could be uh a
bungalow provision in the in the South
build well of course yes so um uh
hopefully even if we got one there that
that's that's an improvement I think but
uh I think um perhaps 10
um is right but anyway uh councelor B
are you happy with that
now um could there be a
minimum chairman it's up to you it's
your
proposal I I need to I need to clear
this point your second is quite happy
with what's
proposed to see it getting watered down
but um Mr chairman
uh councelor Hinton y yeah the the uh
applicant puts in his uh blur that he
put out to people a significant
proportion of the of the homes would be
Bungalows well he said 11% but should we
then watered down a bit because it was
uh a lot less than that but six six out
of 10 being affordable they only leaves
four open market Bungalows he's not I
agree with councelor Barrett he's not
very significant and I think we ought to
have a a percentage of the total total
development as Bungalows rather than a
fixed number in that way uh they can't
wle out of it may they increase the
number of houses then I'm gonna go back
to councelor Barrett it's her proposal
um I I do need you to be clear here
because your second is quite happy at
the moment yeah with what's proposed but
you're the one proposing it so would you
like to start uh Mark do you wanted to
come in just I wonder if if we could um
I know it's slightly irregular just ask
the applicant what they think about this
whether whether they' accept a minimum
of 10 if they're here in this debate
would they actually accept that
explicitly and then we we'd be clearer
i' have to ask about this one the legal
um Can can you advise me on this
aan we've lost
him he's still in the meeting chair I
think
he's I'm here chairman sorry yeah you
you heard all that um the um Mark
Russell chief officer here on planning
at the moment has suggested that we ask
the um applicant whether he would accept
a minimum of 10 was that right yes
yeah yes I that's a reasonable thing to
do I mean I suppose we have to be
mindful that a planning condition
has to be meet the all the usual legal
and policy tests and consent of the
applicants a good thing to have but it
still has to be I'm sorry to Bass it
back to my planner colleagues but it if
if you um I think you have to be
advising the members that it's a
reasonable condition from uh well I've
had a member in fact I'm to um cancel a
hint and says it's the committee that
makes the decision not the applicant
that's true that's true everybody's on
board agreement with him on that
um I think I'd like to put it back to
councelor
Barrett the proposer of this unless Ian
really thinks I should go back to um the
applicant and asked yeah councelor
Hinton is absolutely right I think it's
just I I wanted to be sure what the ADI
the professional advice to members was
about this condition but subject to that
I'll I'll I'll let it rest he the agent
did actually try to say that there was
going to be possibly 10 and um I think
it was cancor Hinton um questioned it
and it might have come down to about
nine um but I I didn't get the feeling
that they weren't going to play ball on
this but councelor Barrett I think it's
back to you again yeah yeah I I think it
you know the committee want to I I think
the committee want to see a significant
number of uh Bungalows on this
development and have been one once bit
and twice shy on this topic and if and
we want I think we want to secure that
uh as and tie it down as much as we
possibly can with minimum wle room if we
can put in um a minimum of 10 um rather
than that being the the uh sort of
Maximum um I I think we should we should
perhaps have a range of between of
between 15 and 10 um I would like to see
that okay well can you work with that
Mark yes I think that that's quite
that's quite Fair chair I think we
probably would put that in uh in the 106
rather than as a condition um so I think
I think if we say at least at least 10
that's better than 10 at least 10 means
you can't might even get more you
probably won't but at least 10 and would
have it 106 that's okay would you be
happy with that councelor Barrett yeah
yeah I think so I'll go to your long
suffer
and are you now happy with the latest
proposal that's put forward yes
at least 10 yeah okay that that that's
got that bit sorted um right now is uh
I've got Adrian Osborne
next thank you m thank you Mr chairman
um I'd just like to get back to this
local connection need I think this needs
and you've you've spoken about this
before and and I've made this uh
obviously very prevalent on on other
applications and that is that the local
connection need and the bab wide need
should come in first for the affordable
housing uh Gateway should not be uh put
in as a in any way to bring in others
from this area without the local people
or the babber area uh being able to to
purchase the affordable housing it would
uh it would have a policy uh within a
policy I suppose if there is one um and
it would actually stop the the situation
that you know and and the members of
this uh committee know have have been
put in on lots of occasions on
applications so I I would like to see uh
a condition or part of of Melanie's uh
Proposal with the affordable housing
that this actually is made noted on this
application and if we don't then you're
just going to get more and more people
coming in from other areas and possibly
uh creating problems with with
affordability in areas thank you uh pcor
Osborne I I understand where you're
coming from and I have strong views
about us as well uh I'm not sure whether
that's actually part of the plan and
process but I'm going to go to Rob now
to see whether we can send a note to the
Housen department or ask somebody else
to pick this up can somebody help us
Rob uh although chair I appreciate your
faith in me on a planning matter I will
delegate um this to Mr as it's not
really my area thank you CH okay I I
thought perhaps that would have been
outside his scope as well uh anyway
let's play past the parel Joe can answer
this one and she'll answer it very well
so I'll pass over to her we will get you
the answer KP Joe all hes on you name
yeah thank you counselor yes um the uh
committee report identifies that we have
100% nomination rights for the
affordable units and it's for the
council to choose um who those units go
to but it it is a decision of the iic
housing team and the policies that we
have with the a strategic housing level
um and there's not a requirement within
planning policies uh to uh go further
into the nomination rights into the
local connection it is a matter which is
directed by other areas of policy within
the council so I don't think it would be
reasonable for us to secure it via
planning condition but certainly I think
it's a matter we can raise um with
Heather Tucker and her team um in
relation to affordable housing
nomination rights could we could we send
a note from this committee that we're
concerned about this point to the Housen
team pointed out that we we strongly
feel that it should be local need first
on the lines that councelor Osborne has
outlined uh can can that be done
separate to the actual plan in uh yes
certainly it can yes I'm sure we can
arrange that coun Osborne would you
accept this yes I would accept it but
once again there I would I would still
say that you need not just local
connection you need the baby side of
this after all we're a district and it
it is the benefit of of local people
within the area and in the area that is
the application is for to have the first
choice of of of affordable housing we we
find
that can that be picked up um um Joe
Hobs can that be that point be picked up
because we we can't insist it in the
planning conditions but can that point
be picked up and forwarded yes certainly
perhaps their councelor we can have a
conversation outside of this committee
and agree um some words in discussion
with the chair to come from this
committee to the housing team um we can
have a discuss separate discussion if
that's okay and could I just ask that in
future when you get large applications
like this with affordable housing on it
that we actually put that into uh into
into that uh area before we go too far
down the line because once we go down
the line it's lost and that's the end of
that thank you I don't think it's a
planning consideration but I think we
need find somewhere to bring this up and
I understand but without the planning
without the planning committee making
these observations uh you're going to
get the same old stuff day in day out
year in year out we may have to uh keep
adding these notes on each one until we
can get it changed well that's the only
way that actually you're going to
actually help the the local people
within the district and the and the
local area thank you right well you'll
take this up with uh Joe after the
meeting uh Robert you're trying to get
me sorry very quickly chair just before
Mr Russell will come in and speak um I
just wanted to check that because
obviously with what councilor Osborne
has just said um we would need to check
that with the proposal in a second um
I'll do that that's just that point
Thank You chair uh councelor Barrett um
are are you happy that we um get a note
sent from the committee after we've had
the words and that
um between councelor Osborne myself the
vice chairman and uh Joe yeah
yeah sorry yeah okay that's that's fine
um Mark sh can I just be clear that
nothing that we've just discussed there
is going to change the recommendation of
this application today no that's it
that's onear going forward yeah yeah
it's it's going to be sent to to to our
hosen department and uh they can then
take it on
board right uh I think I've still got a
cancel Busby I see your hand is uh come
up yeah I think interesting when you
start talking about the the housing
split and whatever it automatically puts
into people's mind that they're
accepting this uh application and I
think before we make the
decision we should remember that
residents oppos this now that's about
50% probably higher than 50% of the
population of spaen now I can't remember
ever seeing an application come before
this committee with such a high
proportion of objections from the locals
these are the people have got to live
with that the consequences of our
decision we should be very careful about
saying yes to something that we wouldn't
want to live next to if we were there so
whilst it's good to start talking about
the housing split and who's going to
live there and whatever let's be sure
that we really want these houses on that
Hillside overlooking these listed
buildings or the proposer and seconder
have already proposed second and I would
assume that they've already taken all
those into consideration before they
made their deliberations on it um uh
councelor
AES
Oh I thought I'd remove my
hand no I just said let's should we get
on with the vote sorry oh
sorry I said you know we've had a
proposer I've second it can we get on
with the vote because we're not in
debate are we right well yeah we're
still in debate but it's been proposed
and seconded that there isn't any more
hands up so with that then members if
you're all finished I'm going to ask Rob
to do a roll call it's been proposed and
seconded by councelor
Barrett um and celor SS that we accept
the officer's
recommendation and we're going to send a
note in due course to the hen Department
um Rob would you like to take us through
the roll call thank you chair so if
members could please respond with for
against or
abstain so councilor a
four councelor Melanie Barrett
four councelor Peter beer
for councelor David
Busby
against councelor John Hinton
against councelor Lee
Jameson
against councelor Mary McLaren
four councelor Adrien
Osborne
against counc Allison Owen
against counc Lee Parker
four and councelor Steven Plum
four thank you chair I make that six
votes to five could I just confirm with
my colleague Mr depre yes indeed I
counted I I also make that six votes for
and five votes against thank you that's
carried thank you members then that is
carried that is
approved um right we're it's now 17
minutes past one um do you wish to take
a break or do you wish to continue with
the next item members get on with it it
ain't going to take very long is it
continue okay that's fine uh Rob do we
do we have the members present who want
there public speakers um councelor arthy
well there not public obviously and
councelor Ma y I will just check um that
councelor Ary has joined us again chair
if you will bear with me one
moment if he hasn't already if he
doesn't speak up now I will just drop
him an email very quickly yes I'm here
that means we're all here chair I
believe neb just yes I'm here thank
thank you celor m um
Samantha can can you take us through
this bear it in mind it's
lunchtime yes I will do thank you CH can
you all hear me yes yeah and you can see
my screen share yes y okay I'll get on
with it then uh this application relates
to land to the rear of the plow and
fleece Public House on Great Green in
corkfield the application came to
committee on 17th of June this year
where members resolved to Grant outline
planning permission for the ction of up
to 28 dwellings the repositioning of
three dwellings under a previous
permission to allow for Access into the
site this was subject to a signed
section 106 agreement to secure
affordable housing contribution public
open space and a highways contribution
towards improvements to a
footpath uh the application comes back
to committee because there were
discrepancies within the committee
report and committee
uh presentation in relation to
affordable housing the committee report
and presentation were based on this
indicative layout plan which clearly
shows 11 affordable dwellings this is
based on 28 new dwellings and three
dwellings to be repositioned at the
entrance to the site bringing the total
number of dwellings within the red line
to 31 the Strategic hous housing team
have confirmed that the contribution for
affordable housing should be 10.85
dwellings for 31 dwellings four comments
can be found in the addendum
papers the developer has offered 11
affordable units on the site
unfortunately I made a mistake in the
committee report under the
recommendation and stated that 12 units
should be provided on the section
106 this figure was taken from a
previous strategic housing consultation
response before the number of dwellings
was reduced from 30 34 to 31 during the
course of the application I apologize
for the confusion officers recommend
that the affordable housing contribution
is amended from 12 to 11 units as per
the Strategic housing teams uh
consultation response this is in line
with the committee presentation on the
17th of June thank you thank you um
right well I have to go through the
procedure see if there's any points of
clarification I'm quite happy it was a
genuine mistake on your part and you
you've you've seen it and rectified it
and um I think all good credit to you uh
on that um it is a m of 10 really but
anyway members is there cancellor
Hinton canel sorry Mr chairman my hand
was still up I I agre with it's not the
first time we've had a mistake and it
won't be the last because we're all
human absolutely well done any other
comments
no uh councelor Plum
sorry uh thanks chair what I was going
to say let's get on I propose that we
accept the officer's
recommendation uh well I I I as much as
I'd like to jump it uh because lunch is
waiting but um I have to go through
public speakers we don't have any I now
must ask the ward members if they wish
to speak um counselor cve Ary and
councelor Margaret Ma I'll take ladies
first um councelor
ma uh thank you thank you Mr chairman um
I won't keep you long so lunch won't be
too delayed as long as I can get this up
on screen um sorry just trying to get it
up on screen right for me anyway um
thank you Mr chairman for allowing me to
speak the opportunity to comment on this
application regarding the affordable
portion of the development is an
opportunity to thank the Developers for
supporting the call and the buildout of
affordable homes for those in need of a
home at a price they can
afford I am sure members of the
committee are well aware of my call for
homes for life which I'm very pleased to
see is is being written into the
emerging joint local plan and is
mentioned here in the papers in front of
you
I would like to comment before I say
anything else on the Landscaping part of
the development and I know that's not a
consideration at the moment um and that
is for the need for the trees and the
hedgeline to the north and Northwest of
the site to be maintained can I just
interrupt you can you stop the clock Rob
uh is that relevant because we're only
dealing with this point of the fact that
um it changes from 12: to 11: we're not
going through the full plan and
application uh at this stage now or are
we um no we're not Mr
chairman sorry councelor M I've just got
to take a VI on it
okay can somebody uh Samantha or Rob or
Ian can somebody tell us this relates
only to the section 106 contribution for
affordable housing so I'm sorry
councelor maybe you must uh keep your
comments purely to the 106 bit uh thank
you thank you Mr chairman I'm sure
you're all well aware that I do like
like to make comments on things but I
will take that back
um just on okay um at this juncture I
would like to thank the planning officer
and her senior manager for their
apologies to us Ward members of the area
that occurred previously with the
numbers regarding the site in the
affordable housing in my book an apology
makes many things better and after all
we are human which another member has
already mentioned and these things
happen the success of this application
being reheard is that the fact that the
number of affordable housing stays at um
a number of 11 giving the hope of a home
for many so thank you very much thank
you and it did show Le on the plans that
were shown to us all the way through um
right uh members I have to ask you have
you any questions for ccel of
maber oh believe it or not there's no
hands gone up well done we'll come to
counselor Clive Ary you also have five
minutes with address the committee have
you anything to say well just very
briefly to to add something to um what
Samantha said um what she didn't mention
was that there had been a suggestion
from the applicant um that the
affordable contribution should be
calculated on the 28 rather than the
31 um and they accordingly were offering
um nine affordable units and a
contribution um so um many thanks to
Samantha for for sorting that out
getting agreement from the applicant and
really we're we're just back to where we
should have been had there not been a a
very slight error in the previous report
so thank you Samantha and I urge you all
just to um approve it thank you
thank thank you very much councelor
arthy members any questions there's no
hands up so I'm going to move through
that um and we're up for debate um I
think canel Plum uh I'll come back to
you
now thank you chair I see no reason why
we should waste any more time at all um
I propose that we accept the officer's
recommendation councelor Barrett are you
second in it yes I am thank you do to
comment thank you it's been proposed and
seconded there's no more hands gone up
so um councelor Barrett your hand is
still
up thank you uh so I'm going to put the
proposal um it's been proposed and
seconded um Robert can you take the roll
call please for approval thank you chair
so as previously members if you could
please respond with for against or
abstain so councelor suit a
four councelor Melanie Barrett four
councelor Peter beer
four councelor David Busby
four councelor John Hinton
four councelor Lee Jameson
four councelor Mary McLaren
four councelor Adrien Osborne four counc
Allison Owen four councelor Lee Parker
four and councelor Steven Plum for thank
you J that is unanimously carried yes
indeed unanimous I agree sorry thank
thank you you too uh right members we've
got to the end of the meeting it's been
a long one uh the date of the next
meeting which was supposed to be
Wednesday 21st of October has been
cancelled because we've no business that
day so the next meeting is now scheduled
for Wednesday the 4th of November at
9:30 I'd like to thank all the officers
all the members all the ward members
that have joined us this morning and the
public who have been watching thank you
for your time and uh